[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle émission consacrée au débat
pour les élections législatives ce soir
nous accueillons au plateau les
candidats qui souhaitent devenir ou
redevenir député de la 10e
circonscription des yvelines
pour des raisons pratiques évidemment
nous ne pouvons pas accueillir les 15
candidats sur un même plateau cette
émission sera donc coupée en trois
séquences distinctes les mêmes thèmes
seront abordés à chaque fois pour cette
première partie nous accueillons
benjamin nicoletta candidat de la france
insoumise aux roberge et va nous
rejoindre
candidate de la république en marche
françois le vot candidat du front
national david douillet candidat
écologiste investi par europe écologie
les verts jean claude husson candidat
investi par le parti socialiste et enfin
le député sortant jean-frédéric poisson
candidat investi par les républicains
élus des e-bonds soir à bout 6 à boussac
et bientôt à bout 6 je rappelle aussi
que vos temps de parole seront
chronométrés vous êtes donc libre
évidemment de vous interpeller entre
vous nous serons tout de même obligé de
surveiller au maximum les qualités des
temps de parole au début de cette
émission avec la question que l'on pose
à tous les candidats
pourquoi les électeurs doivent t'ils
vous faire confiance dimanche prochain
ont commencé avec vous benjamin
nicoletta représentant de la france
insoumise
vous avez la parole pourquoi les
électeurs doivent t'ils nous faire
confiance dimanche
alors bon soir déjà je voulais revenir à
la source de l'assemblée nationale qui
était faite après la révolution
française et qui a un seul objectif
redonner la souveraineté à la population
qui sous la forme de deux assemblées
représentatives de la population
voilà moi je suis un ancien boulanger
artisan boulanger j'ai fait 8 ans
artisan boulanger j'ai été pompier
j'ai été photographiée je suis
aujourd'hui salarié d'une multinationale
où j'ai été élu délégué du personnel
la colistière valérie est actuellement
au chômage donc voilà je pense déjà à
nous deux on représente un petit
échantillon de la france et je suis
convaincu que si nous avons la popu
comment sont comment dire je représente
assure représentation pardon de la
france on aura des lois beaucoup plus
proche du terrain beaucoup plus réaliste
françois le vot pour le pour le front
national c'est votre tour pourquoi les
éditeurs doivent t'ils vous faire
confiance dimanche et bien la 10e
circonscription des yvelines j'y vis
depuis 15 ans maintenant je suis issu de
la société civile c'est important je
suis directeur d'une pme dans
l'environnement et donc je suis au
contact de la problématique économique
et sociale de nos concitoyens au jour le
jour
j'ai des capacités qu'on peut remettre
en commission à l'assemblée nationale
dans l'environnement je viens de le dire
mais aussi dans la défense puisque ça
fait 25 ans que je travaille à la
préparation des la défense
opérationnelle du territoire et donc
c'est une problématique que je connais
très bien il ya aussi que bien au suivi
des élections qui viennent de se passer
à un mois voilà on a été la force
d'opposition et au deuxième tour et
aujourd'hui je crois qu'on ait la force
d'opposition est la seule et l'unique à
savoir la force qui est capable de jouer
contre les désistements réciproques des
uns et des autres voilà david jutier
candidat d'europe écologie à vous la
parole alors qu'aurore bergé nous
rejoindre en plateau bonsoir à david
jutier pourquoi les électeurs doivent
t'ils vous faire confiance au soir
bonsoir toutes et tous écoutez la 10e
circonscription des yvelines est une
circonscription sur laquelle on a déjà
eu une députée écologiste anny
poursinoff qui a prouvé sa capacité de
travail qui a prouvé sa capacité à
comprendre les dossiers qui sont les
points les plus importants du
sud-yvelines on va parler tout à l'heure
de la ruralité des transports de la
santé et l'ensemble des députés
écologistes qui ont été élus en 2012 et
précédemment que ce soit l'assemblée
nationale au parlement européen tous les
jours démontrent leur capacité de
travail leur capacité à comprendre et à
entendre les citoyens et les citoyennes
je pense que j'ai aussi cette capacité
je le montre sur le terrain je suis un
élu un élu de proximité un élu local
moi aussi un citoyen et enfin de la
société civile puisque beaucoup de
personnes se disent citoyens société
civile mais quand on est élu local
conseiller municipal conseil d'agglo et
mais on a aussi une famille on a aussi
un métier moi je travaille tous les
jours
et donc j'ai cette proximité également
et j'ai cette capacité je pense à
apporter le vote utile le vote
alternatif pour la pour la 10e
circonscription des yvelines
or dare g pour la république en marche
même question je vous la dévoile tout de
suite pourquoi les électeurs doivent
nous faire confiance
dimanche la première chose c'est que
j'espère qu'il le vont faire confiance
au président de la république le
président de la république a besoin
d'une majorité pour agir pour réformer
le pays ils ont souhaité dans notre
circonscription placée et mena le
maquereau en tête dès le premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle et puis l'ont
élu très largement au delà du score
national où seront donc la première
chose c'est me faire confiance pour
faire confiance au président de la
république et aux projets que l'on
défend ensuite c'est faire confiance à
notre territoire on a un territoire qui
est à la fois formidable en termes
d'opportunités et qui parfois se
retrouve être un peut l'oublier des
politiques publiques que ce soit le
département qui concentre beaucoup de
ces moyens au nord du département et
oublier un peu le sud
que ce soit après d'autres échelons
régionaux ou nationaux on a l'impression
que finalement on est un peu une réserve
de foncier là où on a d'autres atouts
dont c'est faire confiance aux atouts et
aux opportunités de ce territoire et
avoir un parlementaire qui se bat
évidemment à leurs côtés pour ce
territoire ait pu enfin un peu dans la
veine de ce que disait dévié de jute y
est c'est aussi faire confiance au
renouveau démocratique
moi je travaille dans le privé depuis
dix ans et je pense que voilà il y en a
besoin aussi d'hommes et de femmes qui
ont un langage
mon politique et qui appartiennent à ce
renouvellement à ce renouveau
démocratique
jean claude husson pour le parti
socialiste pourquoi les électeurs
doivent pas nous faire confiance je suis
marié j'ai 51 ans je suis papa d'une
adolescente et j'habite
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines depuis
longtemps je suis fils d'ouvrier je suis
ingénieur de formation j'ai travaillé
dans des grandes entreprises
internationales et je suis toujours au
contact du monde des entreprises
j'ai été bénévole dans des associations
j'en ai présidé et je m'intéresse depuis
plusieurs années à la vie locale
politique
j'ai été élu deux fois maire de saintes
arnoult en yvelines
je suis un homme de terrain je suis un
candidat 9 au plan national avec des
convictions et ça c'est important parce
que à l'assemblée nationale il n'est pas
question d'être dans une opposition
systématique ce serait absurde en tout
cas c'est mon point de vue mais il n'est
pas non plus question d'être aux ordres
et je dirais que je défends les services
publics
je défends la transition écologique je
suis intéressé à l'éthique et la
transparence
et puis je défends aussi le fait que les
citoyens doivent être mieux consulter
tout au long du monde
enfin on termine ce tour de table avec
le député sortant jean-frédéric poisson
la question varie un petit peu pourquoi
les électeurs doivent t'ils vous refaire
confiance puis d'abord jeu
j'habite dans ce territoire depuis 22 ou
23 ans maintenant j ai exercé des
responsabilités locales et à tous les
niveaux
j'ai été maire de rambouillet j'étais
président de la communauté
d'agglomération j'ai accompli dans le
mandat parlementaire qui s'achève
beaucoup de travaux différents sur le
contrôle d'état d'urgence sur la
mobilité sociale des jeunes sur la
prévention du suicide sur beaucoup de
sujets sur lesquels le parlement doit se
prononcer je suis encore pour quelques
jours en tout cas vice président de la
commission des lois de l'assemblée et je
veux continuer à ancrer dans ce
territoire où je suis maintenant depuis
longtemps je connais absolument tous ses
atouts et toutes ses faiblesses
je travaille avec d'ailleurs mes
collègues qui sont élus dans la même
assemblée territoriale que moi depuis
quelques années à tâcher de le
développer au mieux du mieux que nous
pouvons et je crois que tout cela sont
des atouts effectivement pour reconduire
le député que je suis et j'ajoute que en
face des du projet qui sera portée
probablement par une majorité de députés
soutenant emmanuel macron il faudra bien
une forme d'opposition qui sera comme
nous l'avons pratiqué dans break qui
vient de s'achever et c'est à dire nous
voterons des textes qui portent
l'intérêt général comme nous l'avons
fait pendant cinq ans mais il faudra une
forme d' équilibre parce que la
dérégulation qui s'annonce peut paraît
dangereuse pour le pays car je rappelle
évidemment à tous que vos temps de
parole seront chronométrés et on passe
tout de suite aux premiers thèmes de ce
débat la ruralité thèmes majeurs pour
cette circonscription la plus rurale
clairement des yvelines la ruralité ces
problématiques sont désormais bien
connus de tous accès aux soins aux
transports développement du haut débit
agriculture aussi environnement alors si
vous êtes élu député
quelles propositions défendre et vous au
palais beau bourg
on commence avec vous jean claude husson
selon votre tract et vos sites internet
votre site internet vous favoriserez
notamment je vous cite la création de
maisons de service public
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
concrètement en quoi ça consiste et
combien vous en souhaitez par exemple la
2e circonscription pour moi la ruralité
c'est plusieurs aspects c'est bien sûr
la mise en place de maisons de santé je
vais y venir le déploiement de la fibre
optique la création de maisons de
service public et aussi le renforcement
des transports vous me demandez de
commencer par la maison de de santé très
clairement nous manquons de
professionnels de santé chez nous en
campagne mais également en zone urbaine
très urbanisé il manque déjà des
médecins j'ai eu l'occasion de le
vérifier donc nous devons faciliter
l'installation des médecins sur
l'ensemble du territoire pour que les
habitants puissent accéder aux soins et
ça se fait par l'installation de maisons
de santé
concernant la fibre optique ne peut pas
continuer comme ça on peut pas compter
comme ça en disant aux ruraux vous
attendrez 2022 pour obtenir du haut
débit c'est à dire ce qu'ont déjà les
urbains depuis plus de dix ans donc nous
devons déployer la fibre optique est
aujourd'hui le plan de déploiement du
très haut débit et sous financée
dixit le rapport de la cour des comptes
nous devons si c'est une priorité et
c'est la mienne
j'en fais j'en fais la mienne financé à
hauteur suffisante pour déployer la
fibre optique et permettre aux habitants
d'avoir accès aux services la création
de maisons de service public c'est la
même chose les habitants voient les
services s'éloigner donc ils doivent
pouvoir accéder à travers les maisons de
service public à des interlocuteurs
qu'ils soient des interlocuteurs à
distance ou physiquement dans les
maisons de service public et je termine
par le renforcement des transports c'est
complètement inacceptable aujourd'hui de
ne pas pouvoir aller travailler de ne
pas pouvoir aller à l'école aujourd'hui
et des collégiens ne peuvent pas aller
au sport et le nss parce qu a pas de
transport donc nous devons renforcer les
transports fibre optique maison de santé
mais entre services publics et
renforcement des troupes
aurore bergé vous souhaitez en lien avec
le programme présidentiel d'emmanuel
macron que l'ensemble du territoire
notamment soient couverts par la fibre
optique est ce que c'est la priorité
pour les pour les territoires ruraux et
c est ce la 2e circonscription
c'est un sujet qui est essentielle
j'accueillais tout à l'heure nicolas
hulot à saint léger saint léger vous
êtes dans une blanche téléphonie vous
n'avez pas de fibre optique donc c'est
un véritable enjeu d'attractivité de
notre territoire et d'égalité des
chances évidemment entre nos différents
territoires
quand on vit sur cette 10e
circonscription on y vient par choix on
y vient par choix un cadre de vie d'une
qualité de vie et donc il faut pouvoir
bénéficier à la fois de cet atout de
préservation de notre ruralité et de
proximité avec des pôles d'excellence
scientifique universitaire et culturel
et d'attractivité économique très fort
que ce soit à la fois localement avec
saint quentin en yvelines par exemple où
que ce soit avec paris et parfois on a
l'impression que c'est finalement la
double peine ou être les ruraux plus la
grande banlieue malheureusement on voit
les services publics qui s'éloigne on
voit la désertification médicale et on
voit un certain nombre de services dont
on aimerait pouvoir bénéficier comme la
fibre optique et bien ne pas arriver au
sein de territoires la ruralité elle
doit être au coeur du projet qui sera
celui du président de la république il a
déjà affirmé est au coeur de nos projets
en tant que parlementaire parce que
c'est une question d'égalité
monsieur ils sont parlé de la question
des transports je pense qu'il va falloir
accorder de manière directe 51 en
yvelines à rambouillet parce que notre
université de rattachement c'est saint
quentin en yvelines et qu'à un moment on
a quand même un enjeu de proximité ce
matin dans une maison médicale à
montfort l'amaury qui est entièrement
privé
il se trouve qu'ils attendent depuis
plusieurs mois d'obtenir un agrément
pour implanter tout simplement une irm
pourquoi parce que ben il ya des
conflits entre le public entre le privé
résultat est ce qui se passe c'est les
patients qui en sont pour leurs frais
parce qu'ils doivent parcourir des
kilomètres pour pouvoir bénéficier du
même niveau de prestation de services et
c'est ça qu'on doit faire pour notre
réalité
jean frédéric poisson votre idée avoue
vous l'avez dévoilé
récemment pour soutenir les territoires
ruraux c'est la création d'une agence
nationale des territoires ruraux
à quoi servira cette agence concrètement
elle devrait avoir le même rôle que
l'agencé nationale de rénovation urbaine
née pour la campagne je profite de la
présence de monsieur ils sont ici qu'il
comment dire ça permet de préciser et
devrait prendre à son interpellation de
l'autre jour ça n'est pas une mission
d'information ce n'est pas une
commission denquête ça dépasse un groupe
de travail c'est une agence d'état qui
fonctionne comme l'ademe comme l' agence
de l'eau comme un certain nombre
d'organismes qui sont là pour
subventionner soutenir l'investissement
qui est réalisé dans certains
territoires
avec ce principe simple un euro donné
dans les zones urbaines qui sont en
difficulté égale un euro donné pour les
territoires ruraux qui ont besoin est
aussi le doyen de développement je
partage qui vient d'être dit sur eux
évidemment la fibre optique c'est une
mécanique départemental et juridique
extrêmement compliqué sur la fibre
optique et on s'en sortira pas comme ça
même pas au parlement
je suis d'herbes adam berger que ça fait
longtemps qu'on peut aller en train
depuis rambouillet à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines directement
sans aucune espèce de difficulté donc ce
n'est pas la peine d'en raccorder ça
existe déjà
ça existe déjà oui dans les trains ne
roulent pas et qui sont en grève
effectivement y'a du mal mais autrement
ça prend 30 minutes pour faire
rambouillet saint quentin par le news
tous les étudiants tous les espagnols
c'est bien ce n'est pas de dire il n'y a
pas de venir essayer il peut pas y en
avoir pour des tas de raisons mais ça
l'est il n'ya pas c'est ça venez habiter
sur place vous vous rendrez compte que
c'est beaucoup plus facile que ce que
vous pensez et donc à la fin du compte
ce qui est important c'est que lily et
au niveau de l'état et c'est pour ça que
c'est une question législatives la
création de cette agence
au niveau de l'état qu'ils aient la
volonté de maintenir une équité entre
l'urbain qui est en difficulté et le
rural qu'il est presque parce qu'il est
rural si je peux dire mais soyons
attentifs à ce que la force de l'état
est nécessaire dans cette affaire parce
qu'on voit bien le traiter cette
question de la fibre optique à la
communauté d'agglomération depuis des
années avec une difficulté terrible si
effectivement il n'ya pas les décisions
qu'il faut sur le plan étatique pour
faciliter tout cela alors on ira par
cette agence serait destiné à faire ça
je vous rappelle évidemment une nouvelle
fois que vos temps de parole seront
chronométrés le temps défile déjà on est
déjà à plus de trois minutes pour chacun
des candidats base à manille
l'état pour la france a soumis ce quelle
est votre priorité sur la ruralité si
vous aviez un point à défendre à
l'assemblée nationale souhaite élu cet
été déjà je suis aligné avec les
transports et la fibre optique
évidemment parce que c'est un vrai souci
maintenant s'ils doivent en priorité
c'est la santé la santé on a un triste
exemple avec l'hôpital de rambouillet où
on a de moins en moins de médecins on a
de moins en moins de lits on a de moins
en moins de services
et on est en dessous de la moyenne
nationale donc il n'ya pas de secret il
nous soutient un programme qui veut
rouvrir des postes plus de 60000 postes
dans le monde hospitalier
et aussi on souhaite en fait payer les
études de nos futurs médecins et en
contrepartie ces médecins devront faire
leur première année d'exercice dans les
déserts médicaux
autre chose aussi la santé ça va se
répercuter dans notre assiette ici
parlant que j'ai ramené ça j'ai ramené
cette pomme dans cette pomme vous avez
+17 pesticides différents
vous avez un anti un désherbant qui
dépasse de 60 % le taux légal autorisé
et cette pomme provient je vous laisse
deviner de l'école maternelle de
rambouillet voilà c'est un collectif de
parents d'élèves se sont réunis qui sont
soucieux de la cantine de la santé de
leurs enfants et de l'environnement ils
ont fait analyser cette pomme les voilà
ce qu'on trouve ça c'est le résultat
concret de l'impact de la politique
qu'on mène tous les jours aujourd'hui
monsieur poisson qui être député sortant
vous avez voté contre une loi qui
interdisait certains pesticides
dangereux
donc voilà ça il faut savoir si nos
enfants qu'ils aient mangé de contrat
dans cette fois il y avait pas que ça
maintenant dans nos enfants manger ça
donc nous le groupe nous on souhaite
on souhaite une cantine bio de cantine
qui fonctionne en circuit court et une
cantine gratuite
voilà jean frédéric poisson puisque à
moudre après ce sera david douillet
j'invite le jeu par apollon détail j'ai
envie que les auditeurs à consulter la
réponse qui a été donné officiellement
par le maire de rambouillet en séance du
conseil municipal sa figure sur le site
de la ville je conçois que la situation
soit pas complètement satisfaisante
voilà je pense que d'une nécessité de
renouer le dialogue
au moins mais
le maire de rambouillet a répondu je
suis pas en charge de ce dossier là
comme parce que je ne suis pas le maire
de la ville mais les auditeurs trouvant
sur le site de rambouillet des réponses
à l'interpellation puis vient ce n'est
que le lendemain les enfants continuent
à manger ce genre de produits et puis on
invite aussi les téléspectateurs à
regarder vos sites internet respectifs
pour aller plus loin dans le débat david
j'utilise c'est votre tour sur la rue
réalité elle semble se porter sur le
foncier agricole
vous souhaitez protéger le foncier
agricole pour éviter la construction de
projets urbains c'est votre votre idée
c'est le bal des idées effectivement et
je crois que le constat sur l'état de la
ruralité dans ce divine est assez
largement partagée mais il ya quelque
chose qui ressort dans les différentes
interventions
tout le monde fait les mêmes
observations mais tout le monde n'agit
pas de la même manière et moi ce que je
souhaite affirmer de manière claire
c'est que au quotidien personnellement
je vais au-delà des comptes des constats
et j'agis pour protéger les terres
agricoles pour lutter contre les résidus
de pesticides dans les cantines de nos
de nos enfants je vais sur le terrain je
coupe le terrain je n'hésite pas à aller
en justice
j'agis de même pour les transports la
ligne qui relie rambouillet à saint
quentin en yvelines
je la prends tous les jours elle et elle
existe effectivement elle a une utilité
real heureusement qu'elle s'arrête
voilà nommé s'avérait cnn évidemment
elle s'arrête aux frères ou des sarts la
verrière croisière voilà donc il ya
effectivement dire faire le constat qui
est simple à poser et puis après il y à
agir et moi tous les jours j'agis on
parle multisons diesel et est les
liaisons entre rambouillet 50 à 51 à
rambouillet ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on est quasiment à
saturation au niveau de versailles les
trains sont cadencés à 30 secondes près
donc effectivement il faut absolument
améliorer l'existant et sur les sur les
transports
les prérogatives de la région sont très
fortes nous avons lorsque nous étions
responsabilité à la région portée des
budgets d'investissements les
écologistes nous avions la vice
présidence avec pierre serne à la région
aux transports nous avons modernisé
énormément les transports nous avons mis
en place une mesure de justice sociale
et d'équité très forte qui est le passe
navigo à tarif unique 70 euros comme
l'âme pécresse s'étonne on précède
augmenter dès qu'elle est arrivée à la
tête de la région d'ailleurs donc voilà
sur les transports moi aussi je connais
les choses il s'agit pas simplement y
amener en visant les villages et accès à
la gare important c'est à 4 km c'est
assez on a effectivement que des
problématiques sur les transports est ce
qu'on est sur les rails
en tout cas moi je suis heureux que vous
m'interrogez sur le foncier agricole
parce que sur ce premier tour de table
on parle de ruralité et l'agriculture a
été complètement oubliés et
l'agriculture ce n'est pas simplement la
production alimentaire c'est aussi la
préservation de nos paysages
il ya un axe majeur n'apparaît delà de
la santé ce que nous mangeons a un
impact direct sur notre sur notre santé
et là encore on parle leur implantation
médecins de sauvegarde de l'hôpital mais
qui était au côté des collectifs de
l'usagé qui était aux côtés des
syndicats j'en ai pas vu beaucoup moi
j'y étais et je continuerai à l'être si
les électeurs et les électrices me font
confiance françois le vot sur cette
thématique pour le front national sur la
réalité si on se réfère au programme de
marine le pen pour la présidentielle
parmi les points développés
elle souhaite garantir l'égal accès aux
services publics comment vous souhaitez
faire ça par exemple
concrètement justement je vais me baser
sur sur l'élection d'un mois et en même
temps je vais reprendre certaines ont
des points qui ont été citées ici parce
que j'ai l'impression que je vais en
plus en faire la synthèse
j'ai justement sous les yeux le
programme et qu'on défendra en un seul
corps avec un groupe au parlement
notamment le point 138 qui dit garantir
l'accès aux services publics
l'administration
jesson la gendarmerie aussi dans qui se
désertifient ici dans nos campagnes qui
ne dit pas comment forcément c'est ma
question
non tout à fait donc tout simplement en
mettant
en rééquilibrant la politique comme je
vous fais la synthèse vous nous parler
d' agences de la zone rurale moi je lis
le point 139 rééquilibrer la politique
de la ville vers les zones désertifiées
rural c'est à dire permette l'égalité
d'accès à tous ces services c'est normal
alors je veux bien voir aussi que dans
la 10e circonscription je dirais qu'il
ya c'est un peu résumé mais on a on
allait on à la personne qui utilise les
transports qui va travailler dans la
zone urbanisée et qui profitent du cadre
de vie les haines chaque enseignant et
il ya aussi celui qui vit tous les jours
et c'est pas vraiment les mêmes
problématiques qui se présentent à lui
on parle d'agriculture on parle de de
qualité de vie donc ce sont des thèmes
vraiment qu'il faut faune ailée et je
pense aussi aux hôpitaux sur nicole et
en parlait justement quand on voit qu'il
ya délit qui sont enlevés dans l'hôpital
sous prétexte qu'on fait une fusion avec
mignot le pit el niño on enlève des
lions mais on met le l'hôpital de
rambouillet dans un état de précarité
médicale alors que l'on voit des gens
faire la queue les week-ends pour
essayer d'être soigné aux urgences voilà
je trouve que ça c'est vraiment dommage
c'est comment dire une qualité française
qu'on a est cependant en train de perdre
une vitesse démesurée il ya des moyens
pour faire parler des maisons de santé
on peut aussi simplement et en un mot
pour vous donner un exemple concret
simplement défiscaliser des médecins qui
sont en retraite et qui sont prêts à
exercer plus longtemps merci françois le
at on va regarder dans un premier temps
les peut-être les temps de parole qui
vont s'afficher pour voir qui a du
retard outil est en avance dans ce débat
on va voir ça à s'afficher dans quelques
secondes
on va aussi faceo la deuxième thématique
de cette émission on va voir voilà on
voit les temps de paroles qui
s'affichent un peu de retard pour
benjamin nicoletta et puis pour françois
le vot donc on va essayer de
rééquilibrer sa et de la vence aussi
pour jean frédéric poisson deuxième
thématique de cette émission en rapport
avec l'actualité une réforme sur
laquelle vous devrez vous prononcer dès
cet été si vous êtes élu député
les différents projets de loi pour la
confiance dans la vie démocratique c'est
le nom officiel aussi appelé pendant
longtemps loi sur la moralisation de la
vie politique
la réforme a été présentée le 1er juin
dernier par le garde des sceaux françois
bayrou et prévoit notamment la
suppression de la cour de justice de la
république
l'interdiction pour les parlementaires
et ministres de recruter des membres de
famille ou encore la suppression de la
réserve parlementaire ce ne sont que
trois points il ya beaucoup d'exemples
la question est simple si vous êtes élue
députée en l'état actuel la vôtre et
vous et pourquoi françois à l'autre on
va commencer par vous puisque vous avez
un peu de un peu de retard
est-ce que vous voterez en l'état actuel
cette cette proposition ce projet dans
son ensemble oui il est basé sur des
points qui se remettent un petit peu de
morale en politique c'est le but et je
pense que en effet il en faut je vais
citer une citation de l'esprit des lois
puisque justement c'est le sujet de
notre débat d'aujourd'hui on ne conçoit
pas de démocratie sans vertus et c'est
noté ce que qui disait ça 1748 je crois
de mémoire et donc voilà c'est très
simple il faut de la virtus c'est à dire
qu'en fait il faut trouver des
c'est un peu la première question que
nous avons posée la confiance pourquoi
vous ferez temps de confiance il faut se
trouver des députés des intéressés
qu'ils soient pas spécialement carrière
et carriériste à qui on ne laisse pas la
chance de faire une carrière évident
simplement qu'il soit complètement
convaincu de ce qu'ils disent et qui
développent leurs lois de cette manière
ensuite je pense qu' il faudrait aussi
dans le renouveau démocratique dont on
parle qu'on s'appuie aussi sur des gens
qui ont malheureusement mais je suis
pour les modèles des élus sur des gens
je sais que même verger répondra le
soutien de monsieur juppé ont monsieur
juppé pour moi ce n'est pas un modèle
tel que je le conçois même si là il a
pris les sablais enfin y ont été
condamnés dont ils sont suspicion
absolument donc voilà je dis simplement
que nos concitoyens ont besoin d'avoir
un modèle un modèle débuts voilà alors
moralisation pourrait même exagéré les
peines pour un élu qui triche ça serait
bien aussi
alors c'est ce qui est prévu vous pas
d'ici
les bébés de marque est encore en tant
que dimanche je vais bien voilà que
l'élu c'est que votre point de vue on
sait que ça a été un point beaucoup mis
en avant par jean luc mélenchon pendant
la campagne est ce que l on satisfait ce
que ce projet vous satisfait oui mon
problème plus loin je pense parce que la
confiance c'est quelque chose qui se
gagne déjà
donc nous on est tous signataires la
charte anticorps anti corruption que
j'ai ramené ici je sais que il semble
que david jutier à cette charge sais pas
ce qu'il en est pour vous vous devez la
connaître je vous invite à le regarder
parce que justement ça va être les actes
les actes qui vont compter alors etc
ouais voilà ça les regarde anti
corruption voilà et nous on aimerait
aller plus loin parce qu'on aimerait
pouvoir mettre en place un référendum
révocatoire des élus
pourquoi parce qu'on on estime que l' on
le voit bien pendant le temps des
élections c'est qu'il ya beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de promesses
on va élire une personne sur des
promesses avec aucune garantie et si
cette possibilité d'un référendum
révocatoire tombe
je pense que les promesses seront
beaucoup plus réfléchie et mûrie dans la
tête elles ne sont plus dit juste pour 6
pour séduire les personnes
donc voila nous on veut vraiment aller
plus loin on est signataire de sacchi la
loi actuelle si vous êtes élu député
vous ne voterez pas enfin les projets
nos six chiens à trois on a beau y en as
2 déshérités c'est toujours mieux que
rien mais on aimerait aller plus loin
parce que parce que comme le dit vous
allez trop projet peut-être de porter un
nouveau projet de loi à l'assemblée
nationale souhaitait lui qu'il irait
plus loin mais nous on aimerait proposer
ce référendum révocatoire je pense que
ça changerait tout le parcours parce que
on entend beaucoup beaucoup mais on
on a pas d'actes concrets à proposer moi
j'aime bien voir des choses concrètes
on propose très bien qu est ce qu est ce
qu on fait concrètement si ça si on a
cette épée damoclès sur la tête je
promets qu'on gouvernera le pays
différemment et jean frédéric poisson si
vous êtes réélu député
cette loi c'est ce projet de loi je suis
d'accord avec les dispositions qui
prévoient d'interdire lé en bouche d'un
membre de sa famille plus et c'est
quelque chose que j'aimerais même jamais
fait donc je n'ai pas deux j'ai pas de
difficulté avec ça je suis d'accord avec
le renforcement des peines pour les élus
qui sont indélicats pendant l'exercice
de leur mandat j'avais même pendant le
premier débat de la primaire la droite
et du centre fait cette proposition en
imaginant des peines plancher qui
dépasse la durée du mandat le plus long
c'est à dire six ans dans la république
pour les sénateurs ou les mères donc le
10 ans ça me paraît raisonnable et ça
permet effectivement de façade ne permet
pas de revenir facilement dans le
circuit quand on en a été écarté
je suis extrêmement gênée par la
suppression de la haute cour de justice
qui était précisément fait pour marquer
la séparation des pouvoirs entre
l'exécutif et l'autorité judiciaire et
donc ça ça me gêne quant à la
suppression de la réserve parlementaire
très franchement tant que l'état
français sera jacobins et il le sera
encore pour un moment il y a un tas
d'associations et beaucoup de communes
qui pour une partie de leurs projets de
leur financement de leur matériel
dépendront de cette réserve
parlementaire pour fonctionner
correctement j'ai en tête une
association que j'ai aidé il ya trois ou
quatre ans j'ai trop à qui j'ai dû
verser 1000 euros de réserve
parlementaire pour permettre l'achat
d'une tente pour remettre les prix du
concours qui faisait dehors ça
représentait ses 1000 euros une
cinquantaine d'années de leurs bénéfices
annuels moyens voyez que ça me paraît
pas non plus complètement complètement
utile la réserve parlementaire et les
publications soient votre âge
ses partisans y étais pas je les ai
jamais oublier
tout ça est public c'est la procédure
budgétaire qui la désigne tout ça ce
sont des financements fléché qui
viennent de l'état enfin voilà le
système ne paraît pas si sûr s'il faut
des contrôles supplémentaires
allons-y mais ne supprimons pas ce qui
est parfois une bouffée d'oxygène pour
des communes ou des associations
david jutier pour avoir écologie les
verts votre point de vue sur sur ses
compétences sans gloire dans cette loi
de moralisation de la vie politique
désormais de confiance dans la vie
publique quelque chose comme ça c'est
intéressant ce glissement sémantique je
vais y revenir juste après si vous le
permettez passé de la moralisation à la
confiance n'est pas neutre dans le choix
des mots cette loi elle contient un
grand nombre de mesures que nous
proposons depuis des années qu'ils n'ont
jamais été mis en oeuvre ni par les
républicains y parlait le parti
socialiste lorsqu'il était
respectivement au pouvoir donc
évidemment dans une attitude que j'ai
toujours annoncé si je suis élue députée
je voterai les différentes mesures qui
vont dans le bon sens qui correspondent
à ce qu'on a toujours défendu il en sera
de même avec les mesures de transition
écologique puisque nicolas hulot a été
nommé comme ministre d'état
donc c'est un excellent point il est
entouré de personnes qui sont totalement
anti écologiste qui l'ont démontré
depuis des années va avoir besoin de
députés écologistes donc à nouveau s'il
a besoin d'un soutien
je soutiendrai les mesures qui vont dans
le bon sens et puis pour revenir à cette
différence entre la moralisation et là
il a confiance
effectivement on peut pas passer par la
loi pour ramener de la morale en
politique qui concerne pas uniquement
des des règles mais une manière de se
comporter devant les électeurs et des
électrices une manière de respecter les
programmes que l'on a défendu les idées
que l'on en avait vendu 2 6 de
s'inscrire dans une cohérence dans son
parcours politique et dans son histoire
et sa la loi ne le permet pas et donc
j'invite chacun à regarder les parcours
politiques des différents candidats et
candidates ici présentes et à regarder
quelle est la cohérence à qui peut-on
faire confiance qui a soutenu un jour
tel candidat un jour un autre qui a été
fidèle à une formation alors que les
programmes changer en permanence et je
pense par exemple ici à jean claude
husson dont le programme est là en ciel
le préau le programme présidentiel a
changé aussi tôt benoît hamon des faits
le programme a été complètement
revue donc je pense que ça c'est une
attente très forte de la part des
françaises et des français que leurs
hommes et leurs femmes politiques soient
constants dans leurs positions et dans
leurs valeurs saison aurore bergé
candidat de la république en marché plus
d'emploi 10 euros pour conclure ce tour
de table et puis la carte blanche à
lille 0-1 la question est est ce que
vous feriez sur sur la confiance
en effet moi je suis assez sensible aux
thermes qui a été choisie on a besoin de
restaurer la confiance on l'a vu pendant
la campagne présidentielle où une partie
du débat a été confisqué par les
affaires à la fois de françois fillon et
de marine le pen mais ça a permis aussi
de faire émerger un débat qui était
essentiel qui était celui de l'éthique
en politique et celui de la confiance
qu'on pouvait ou non avoir dans nos élus
je pense que tous ici ont toutefois
certains d'entre vous ou nous sommes
élus locaux et on a côtoyé dans cette
campagne on continuera à le faire
beaucoup d'élus locaux et on souffre
beaucoup de l'opprobre aussi qui est qui
et lancer l'anathème qui est lancée du
tous pourris et donc on a besoin un
moment aussi de faire le ménage entre
ceux qui sont vertueux ceux qui
respectent les règles ceux qui jouent le
jeu aussi du renouvellement démocratique
c'est à dire qu il ne cumule pas des
fonctions en permanence et les cumuls
pas dans le temps et c'est ce que permet
ce projet de loi c'est à la fois
restauré la confiance parce que on
arrête le cumul dans le temps des
mandats en plus du cumul en même temps
je pense que cet essentiel pour
régénérer la vie politique pour avoir
des gens qui viennent de la société
civile pour pas avoir des gens qui vont
faire carrière mais gens qui ont offert
un 2e mandat de parlementaire à titre
personnel je pense que deux mandats de
parlementaire ça suffit parce que
l'énergie qu'on y met pendant dix ans
est suffisante aujourd'hui pour ma
génération par exemple aucun de perdre
aucune personne de ma génération ne va
rester pendant 10 15 ans ou 20 ans dans
la même entreprise ou même niveau de
poste
pourquoi il y aurait une exception pour
les élus ça me paraît absurde donc oui
je voterai j'vote règles fierté ce
projet de loi et puisque vous faisait
référence manière moqueuse a aussi en
alain juppé moi je l'assumé je suis
extrêmement fier l1 juppé fait une
exception en ma faveur
en faisant jouer de me soutenir je suis
fier de bénéficier du soutien du
président de la république et de celui
d'alain juppé d'autres ont le soutien de
christine boutin je sais que vous en
êtes proche désormais puisqu'elle a
appelé à voter pour vous mais moi je
préfère avoir le soutien à l'enjeu
jean claude dusseau pour conclure ce
tour de table sur sur le projet de loi
présenté par françois bayrou il ya
quelques jours maintenant je voterai
cette loi en fonction de différents des
propositions du gouvernement tout
simplement sur le cumul des mandats je
suis d'accord sauf que faire une loi
pour prévoir tous les cas de cumul c'est
compliqué très compliqué avec les vice
présidents de syndicats et autres donc
un éviter le cumul par le financement
c'est à dire interdire un cumul des
financements des indemnités qui dépasse
l'indemnité du parlementaire c'est une
piste qui me paraît plus intéressante a
été proposé récemment travaillé sur les
conflits d'intérêts entre les
entreprises et privés et les
administrations
le fait que des personnes passent de
l'un à l'autre et reviennent à au
premier dans les mêmes fonctions
ça c'est une difficulté c'est même un
contournement de
la démocratie par des systèmes
d'influencé donc le troisième point
c'est travailler sur le fonctionnement
de la commission de déontologie même si
elle remet un rapport tous les ans il y
a des explications nécessaires devant
les par le parlement sur les choix
qu'elle peut qu'elle peut faire je suis
contre enfin je suis pour la suppression
de la réserve parlementaire parce qu'il
faut en terminer avec le saupoudrage je
suis pour la définition d'objectifs
clairs et l'atteinte de nos objectifs
si on veut déployer la fibre optique il
faut la financer
on ne peut pas sous financés comme média
cour des comptes le déploiement de la
fibre optique le financement des partis
politiques est pas question pour moi
d'accepter un financement fonction de
sondages entendu ça je pense pas que ça
viendra sur la table j'ose espérer en
tout cas quand elle à la constance je
suis parfaitement constants c'est un peu
facile de confondre jean claude husson
est un parti politique
je n'accepte pas ça j'ai défendu le
programme de benoît hamon et je continue
à le défendre qu'il ya d'autres aspects
table pour les exactement l'emploi du
son je peux terminer plus râler si je
suis jean claude husson et je défends le
programme qui est le mien je suis un
député indépendant je les dis des
valeurs j'ai des convictions avec marc
et jean claude husson
bien sûr il est publié sur mon site
internet il suffit d'aller loueurs et ne
sais pas ce que c'est le mien et je suis
socialiste
une nouvelle fois j'invite à aller plus
en profondeur au site internet respectif
avant de passer à la carte blanche qui
vous permettra de mettre en avant le
point que vous souhaitez chacun on va
regarder peut-être une dernière fois vos
temps de parole qui vont s'afficher
j'en suis sûr dans quelques secondes
avec des écarts un plus ou moins
importants on va les voir là justement
s'afficher voilà donc jean frédéric
poisson
jean claude husson et puis david jutier
vous aurez entre guillemets des petites
cartes blanches laurent verger aussi et
beaucoup plus de temps pour benjamin
nicoletta et françois le hot
et puis si c'est en parle ne sont pas
parfaitement respecté nous essaierons
dans la semaine qui arrive de les
réguler on commence avec vous jean
frédéric poisson on prend l'ordre
inverse de tout à l'heure vous parliez
an dernier pour l'introduction vous
parler désormais en premier votre carte
blanche le point que vous souhaitez
mettre en avant en quelques secondes
malheureusement quelques secondes
seulement l'agriculture parce que c'est
un des premier poste d'exportation pour
le commerce extérieur français
c'est une filière dans laquelle il ya
une très grande diversité de métiers est
extrêmement présente dans notre
territoire sous beaucoup d'aspects elle
nécessite elle a besoin d'une réforme de
l'europe ambitieuse dont je ne vois pas
le commencement du début dans les
intentions du président de la république
même le contraire et je pense que
effectivement le soutien du
développement économique dans d'autres
territoires
la capacité d'innovation de nos
agriculteurs sur place vous pourrez
donner beaucoup de beaucoup d'exemples
et le fait que nous ayons nous comme et
du coup je dis tout parce que monsieur
jean monsieur j qui ont été associés à
ces décisions sur le le un atelier de
découpe qui est un équipement utile très
petit mais utile sur notre territoire ça
veut dire que nous avons pour
l'agriculture une ambition à la fois
européenne stratégique est vaste et en
même temps extrêmement concrètes très
ancrée et très local jean claude husson
pour le parti socialiste votre votre
carte blanche à vous vous n'avez pas non
plus beaucoup de temps moi ce que j'aime
c'est rencontrer les français c'est ce
que je fais déjà en étant maire de
saint-arnoult d'ailleurs j'agis j'agis
pour l'environnement en ayant pris
nombre de mesures sur le zéro phyto en
rejoignant
le parc de chevreuse en réduisant la
consommation d'électricité en passant
par deux lettres en fallait les exemples
sont nombreuses et l'environnement c'est
une préoccupation que je le fais par le
pragmatisme et le pratique notamment la
réduction des déchets la réduction du
gâchis dans les restaurants scolaires
mais j'aime rencontrer les français
c'est ce que je continuerai à faire j'ai
rencontré un entrepreneur qui proposait
de recycler de loups au sein d'une
maison j'ai rencontré les personnels
d'une maison de retraite qui font
attention à nos anciens et mettent en
place des stratégies pour maintenir
l'autonomie le plus longtemps possible
j'ai rencontré le présidente
d'association qui défend les intérêts
des personnes à mobilité réduite j'ai
rencontré des élus du territoire qui se
battent pour défendre les habitants
tous les jours j'ai encore une
association d'entrepreneurs
nous avons parlé de création d'emplois
donc j'aime rencontrer les français
c'est ce que je continuerai à faire
parce que je serais un député citoyens
aurore bergé à vous pour votre carte
blanche
vous souhaitez mettre en avant bien moi
je ne veux pas que dans le sud est y nom
devienne une réserve foncière et
uniquement ça et pour avoir parlé
évidemment vos élus mais tout simplement
aux habitants je pense vraiment on vient
ici par choix et je voudrais qu'on
continue à venir ici par choix et non
pas par contrainte pour que ce soit
possible je pense qu'il va falloir
réformer la loi sru c'est à dire celle
qui gère aujourd'hui qui règlemente la
question du logement
oui on est une région un département
sous tension où on a besoin de continuer
à construire parce qu'on a besoin de
loger tout simplement les gens par
contre on peut pas continuer à nous
demander de construire toujours plus
sans avoir les services publics qui
viennent derrière et donc on a besoin de
faire parler de faire dialoguer les
différentes collectivités
on a besoin que le département réoriente
ses moyens pour pas que tout soit
fléchés vers le nord du département et à
ce titre je pense que la question de la
fusion entre le département des
hauts-de-seine et des yvelines doit être
doit faire l'objet d'une très large
consultait consultations et
concertations et pas juste être décidé
entre présidents de départements donc
voila moi la carte blanche c'est ça
c'est maintenir cette qualité de vie ce
cadre de vie et donc ne pas être cette
réserve foncière réforme est à louer ses
rues pour que la construction de
logements à elles deux
avec l'avancée de service public et le
lien qu'on doit avoir avec les
collectivités territoriales qui doivent
nous aider y compris l'état pour le
mettre en oeuvre
françois le vote pour le front national
votre carte blanche vous avez un peu
plus de temps c'est vrai puisque vous
êtes un peu plus de quatre minutes
allez-y pour votre carte blanche alors à
prendre un risque parce qu'il ya plein
de sujets à traiter
je vais parler de l'immigration et
l'insécurité parce que c'est un sujet
d'actualité
j'aurais pu parler de l'adversaire est
aussi un dr je suis assez agréablement
surpris que même berger reprennent la
question 97 324 de marion maréchal-le
pen de juin 2016 est cité mazan dans le
vaucluse en exemple elle disait en effet
qu'il fallait pas compromettre
l'équilibré budgétaire des communes
entre le logement et l'emploi
donc je sais qu'ils veulent mais ça
m'étonne pas que j ai choisi
l'immigration et l'insécurité évidemment
pourquoi évidemment parce que c'est un
sujet d'actualité
l'écho républicain a demandé quelle est
la priorité quelle est votre première
proposition de loi vous feriez si vous
êtes élu excusez moi j'étais un confrère
j'ai vu les agences de l'onu a prévu la
loi sru
moi j'ai préféré parler d'un effet de
deux des fiches s pour islamisme et de
leur expulsion tu dis c'est certainement
dans ce sens là que donnerait plus de
pouvoir juridique ne serait-ce qu'en
s'appuyant sur le code pénal l'article
411 thierry cat intelligence avec
l'ennemi je renvoie tous les juristes le
soin de le relire je voulais simplement
dire que voilà on a un problème
d'insécurité dans ce pays encore tout à
l'heure il ya une heure ou 2 1
quelqu'un en criant c'est pour la syrie
a asséné deux coups de marteau un
policier sur le parvis de notre-dame
alors moi je n'ai été publié avec ma
proposition de loi le lendemain à
londres on a sept morts et 48 blessés
j'aime je vois la jambe ou dit pas sur
la tristesse de ce genre d'actualité
je dis simplement qu'on l'a prévu qu on
le sait que ça ne s'arrêtera pas qu'on
fait des pas des mesurettes mais on fait
des commissions réfléchi et autres ça
c'est bien il faudrait prendre des
mesures réelles parce qu'il ya des gens
autour de nous qui sont prêts à
continuer ouais ça c'est très important
ensuite l'immigration évidemment il faut
rétablir entre les îles cc l'immigration
de sécurité pour messi liées parce qu'on
voyait très bien que on voit oui au
bataclan au stade de france par dont une
personne est arrivée sur les côtes
grecques était remonté en alesi terminé
c'est parce qu'on a gagné dans blanche
ils vont hélas peu de temps maintenant
absolument donc je dis simplement qu'il
faut rétablir nos frontières parce qu'il
faut savoir où on en est ça c'est
important
et cette politique de deux de
remplacement de submersion migratoire
est intolérable aujourd'hui dans le
système aujourd'hui on n'a pas d'emploi
on ne peut pas accueillir tout le monde
david jutier pour écologie les verts
vous avez très peu de temps pour poser
une question en avance dans quel type de
monde nous voulons nous vivre demain est
ce que nous voulons vivre dans un monde
globalisé dans un monde où ce sont les
échanges commerciaux se sont les
échanges financiers qui dictent les
politiques publiques et je pense là
notamment au traité transatlantique qui
ont été proposées qui sont très
fortement soutenu par le président de la
république et par et par ses soutiens
moi je ne pense pas que la priorité
doivent doivent être justement de
soutenir à tout prix le grand le
commerce mais au contraire le commerce
international la finance mais au
contraire de permettre aux territoires
aux élus locaux aux citoyens ou
citoyennes de prendre leur décision sans
être sous la menace permanente de
recours juridiques venant de grands
groupes et puis aujourd'hui la feuille
de route une feuille de route sur la
réserve a été a été proposé je ne veux
pas d'un code du travail qui précarisent
qui lui brise et donc je serai très
vigilant à protéger les salariés va
jamais
vous concluez cette émission vous avez
un peu plus de temps vous avez près de
deux minutes pour conclure
donc moi en fait j'aurais aimé utiliser
cette carte blanche pour éclaircir un
petit peu la situation
nous avons un nouveau président nous
avons un nouveau gouvernement ce
gouvernement est composé de parti
socialiste de raids des républicains on
a un premier ministre qui était ancien
porte-parole d'alain juppé qui défend
des la retraite à 65 ans qui défend dès
le passage aux 39 heures la suppression
de 36 ans de 300 mille postes de
fonctionnaires on a on a quoi de toute
sorte de ministre on a mis de
l'éducation ancien numéro 2 de nicolas
sarkozy qui a lui même supprimé 80 mille
postes dans l'éducation
on a des anciens combattants comme
gérard collomb qui est élu depuis 1978
voilà un patchwork comme ça je dis pas
que ça ne marchera pas pourquoi pas ça
déjà été tentée dans l'histoire avec
l'ump entre autres simplement on a par
exemple aurore bergé qui est soutenu par
par annie jupé aussi donc pourquoi pas
mais tout ça pour dire que si vous êtes
contre de casser le code du travail par
ordonnance il faut voter françaises
soumises
si vous êtes contre les deux perdent
deux heures supplémentaires au delà de
35 heures
il faut voter france 1 5012 sol la seule
opposition humaniste je tiens à préciser
alors pourquoi pourquoi je dis ça alors
quoi je dis ça parce que nous avons eu 7
millions ne voit quand même et un député
seul même s'il fait partie d'un parti
mais qui se défend seul n'aura pas du
tout le même pouvoir que si on a un
groupe majoritaire ou un groupe
conséquent
donc ça c'est important que les lecteurs
en ait conscience parce qu'il faut se
battre contre ça on va supprimer 100 m
libre à cause d'autres fonctionnaires à
les y terminer vous rattraper votre
retard donc je rattrape mon retard je
pense que j'ai pas pu jim et j'ai dû
laisser un dernier point peut-être se
passe quelques secondes vous souhaitez
mettre un point bas la csg aussi parce
que le cg on en parle beaucoup pour
augmenter pouvoir d'achat mais ça réduit
le pouvoir d'achat de nos retraités ça
c'est important
donc il faut pas il faut prendre
conscience du programme qui arrive
ces ordonnances n'est pas rien et il
faut réagir à ça il faut une vraie
opposition
merci
à bout 6 pour votre venue votre
participation à ce débat tout de suite
de nouveaux candidats vont nous
rejoindre au plateau en attendant
nicolas d'andry vous présente les enjeux
de cette circonscription avec ce sujet
un territoire entre ruralité et zones
urbaines la 10e circonscription recouvre
le sud-est du département des yvelines
de ville de près de vingt mille
habitants en rambouillet et maurepas et
plusieurs communes rurales entouré de
village comme montfort l'amaury ou
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines au coeur des
enjeux sur ce territoire l'agriculture
avec plus de 50 % de surfaces agricoles
cultivées les attentes sont importantes
sur ce secteur dominé par l'activité
céréalières et maraîchères
autre thématique dominante la ruralité
lors du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle dans cette
circonscription
emmanuel macron est arrivé en tête avec
27 89% des voix talonnée par françois
fillon
avec 27% des suffrages arrive ensuite
jean luc mélenchon et marine le pen à 15
% et 14 % député sortant jean-frédéric
poisson se présente sous les couleurs du
parti chrétien-démocrate investi par les
républicains il veut accéder à une
troisième législature avec la volonté de
poursuivre son travail dans le domaine
de la lutte contre le terrorisme
face à lui la candidate de la république
en marche aurore bergé conseillère
communautaire à saint quentin en
yvelines
ex-membre du parti les républicains elle
a rallié emmanuel macron pendant la
campagne présidentielle
elle s'engage notamment sur les
thématiques de l'égalité homme-femme du
progressisme et de l'union européenne
en embuscade face à ce duel annoncé
benjamin nicoletta sous la bannière de
la france insoumise il doit faire face à
la division de la gauche
le maire socialiste de saint-arnoult
jean claude husson corinne auribeau pour
le pcf ou encore l'élu rambolitains
l'écologiste david jutier autres
divisions du côté front national
françois le hôte devra faire face à
philippe chevrier président du parti du
front libérés ils soutiennent tous les
deux une position souverainiste et
protectionniste dans le domaine
économique et sociétal au total les
électeurs auront le choix parmi cette
liste de quatorze candidats sur une
circonscription ancrée à droite depuis
excepté en 2010 lors d'une élection
législative partielle qui avait vu la
victoire de l'écologiste anny poursinoff
face à jean frédéric poisson
plus de 88 mille électeurs sont appelés
aux urnes ce dimanche 11 juin et trois
nouveaux candidats nous ont rejoints en
plateau pour ce débat pour la 10e
circonscription des yvelines laurent
burson candidat divers-droite investi
par le parti libéral-démocrate dominique
chambon suppléant de corinne auribeau
candidate communiste investi par le
parti communiste français et puis audrey
q n'y sont ni date divers investi par
l'union populaire républicaine bonsoir à
tous les trois sont quelques précisions
avant de commencer cette deuxième partie
ce deuxième débat nous avions convié
philippe chevrier candidat d'extrême
droite investi par le fonds libérés à
participer à cette émission mais celui
ci a décidé de décliner notre
proposition s'estimant lésés de ne pas
participer à la première partie de
l'émission joël bosch de son côté
candidat de debout la france ni n'a pas
voulu venir pour je le cite précisément
des raisons professionnelles
autre précision à trensacq à ce débat
vous avez tous les trois a pu voir
comment se déroulait le débat votants de
paroles seront chronométrés qu'on
comptait pour essayer au maximum de les
respecter
première question toujours la même
pourquoi les électeurs doivent t'ils
vous faire confiance à oran burson vous
avez la parole en premier
donc bon soir donc effectivement je me
creuse
je suis donc leur augures sont je suis
donc président du parti libéral des
yvelines et je suis maire adjoint membre
pas et je défends dans cette dans cette
élection
d un programme qui n'est pas qu'ils nous
serons qu'il ne se retrouve pas dans les
autres candidats je défends la liberté
la liberté d'entreprendre la liberté de
créer mais également la liberté
vis-à-vis de l'état aujourd'hui l'état
domine notre notre façon de vivre et je
pense que les français et notamment les
et les électeurs donc de la 10e
circonscription donc sont tout à fait
capables sur certains domaines de
prendre en main leur propre leur propre
façon de vivre
dominique la chambre ont pour le parti
communiste dites nous pourquoi les
électeurs doivent t'ils vous faire
confiance dimanche prochain déjà je
voudrais excuses et corinne reebok et la
titulaire et qui est hospitalisé pour
quelques jours à venir bien donc je les
remplacer au pied levé j'ai préparé
quelques notes et je vais vous commencez
par vous citez est quelque chose qui a
dit quelqu'un que vous aimez
certainement le parti communiste a
toujours été là dans les communes avec
ses militants et ses représentants pour
aider les gens pour ma part j'ai
simplement envie que les gens puissent
vivre un peu mieux et qui n'est pas de
problèmes pour boucler leurs fins de
mois et remplir leurs caddies c'est
josiane balasko qui a dit ça avec tout
son coeur est en effet nous on est là en
permanence pas seulement - des élections
pour défendre les gens pour défendre les
services publics pour défendre l'hôpital
au sein du collectif de défense et de
développement de l'hôpital de
rambouillet pour le logement social pour
la gratuité de la dc était encore
dernièrement à distribuer au péage de
saint-arnoult pour supprimer ce paiement
qu'en plus notre député actuel peuvent
être fiers de leur travail et de leur
vote qui ont été utiles aux gens et à la
colle le vote de l'accord 21 la
transparence dans la vie publique contre
le cumul des mandats contre la fraude
fiscale et la grande délinquance
économique et financière nous sommes
nous sommes donc comme porteur de
profondes transformations de la société
et on a une particularité nous aussi
c'est que on veut prendre l'argent à
ceux qui on nous trouve pour en donner à
ce qu'on nous passe et audrey queniez
enfin pour ceux pour terminer ce premier
tour de table pourquoi les électeurs
doivent-ils faire confiance à vous et à
lui perd dimanche prochain mais d'abord
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité ce
soir donc je suis au drake unis j'ai 32
ans je suis non
titienne professionnel je suis ingénieur
dans l'industrie automobile
j'ai fait des études supérieures j'ai
connu le chômage
j'ai franchi le pas d'une reconversion
par des études en alternance et
aujourd'hui j'ai la grande chance de
gérer au quotidien une équipe des
projets mais aussi des conflits et
surtout des priorités jeu j'ai fait
partie pendant très longtemps de ses
dégoûtés de la politique
jusqu'à ce qu'en 2015 je rencontre lupe
air avec monsieur asselineau et que je
découvre que l'éthique en politique
pouvait encore exister jeu monsieur
asselineau a prouvé pendant la
présidentielle qu'il ne savait mieux que
quiconque les reconnaître et parker les
traités européens
et c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui j'aurai
la chance d'avoir cette équipe derrière
moi qui connais les traités et par
exemple pour ne citer que le dernier
événement en date la méconnaissance des
traités de par notre gouvernement nous
coûte 4 milliards de remboursements de
taxes indûment perçues sur nos
entreprises donc voilà il faut aussi
citer les ogm qui nous auront coûté 10
millions d'euros parce qu'ils ont été
retranscrites trop tard dans nos lois
françaises donc voilà cette équipe qui
connaît les lois de notre de notre pays
qui nous gouvernent
on passe à la thématique principale de
cette émission la ruralité un sujet
forcément très large très vaste qui
comprend notamment le développement des
transports l'agriculture le
développement économique aussi l'accès
aux soins ou encore le haut débit
dominique chambon si l'on se réfère au
programme du parti communiste pour les
élections législatives
on peut lire que vous êtes favorable le
pcf un plan de relance des services
publics et celui ci passe notamment par
la fin de la baisse des dotations
collectivités locales ou encore la
mobilisation de nouvelles recettes
est-ce que vous pouvez vous préciser
peut-être ses idées pour commencer où
vous les postulats tout nombre parce que
alors pour ce qui est du développement
des services publics donc jeu qui peut
esquisser la question de l'hôpital de
rambouillet
c'est un service public de grande
importance dans la région pour pour le
développer il faudrait des ressources
financières dont on le prive il faudrait
des objectifs de développement publique
qu'il n'a qu' on ne lui donne pas parce
que la loi bachelot d'une part et est
poursuivi par la loi en touraine en font
une entreprise à visée de rentabilité
financière ce qui est complètement
incompatible avec la notion de service
public
résultat l'hôpital a de grosses
difficultés donc voilà un développement
développement des services publics et
bien il ya un gros problème pour les
gens qui prennent le train les
transports pour les transports en
général bon le train les gens ils
viennent de la campagne de très loin par
exemple ils ont peut-être déjà un petit
peu de chemin pour aller prendre leur
autocar ensuite il soit ils prennent un
docteur qui les a mais la gare de
rambouillet ensuite ils prennent un
train et peut-être même avec des
changements pour l'heure le rer
ce qui fait que avec un car toutes les
demi heures seulement le soir quand
quand les trains ont du retard et bien
ils sont besoin de moi je pense qu'il
faudrait là actuellement c'est une
demi-heure de car il faut tous les
quarts d'heure nous faut au moins un car
tous les quarts d'heure et pour ce qui
est de des retards de train et bien il
faut cesser de faire des économies sur
l'entretien des trains c'est la cause
c'est les c'est les directives
européennes qui veulent amener la
concurrence dans les chemins de fer et
pour ça et bien la sncf et semer
concurrentiel au niveau de rentabilité
financière ce qui n'est ce qui n'est pas
du tout
laurent burson j'imagine que vous
partagez pas totalement ce qui vient
d'être dit pour pour le parti
libéral-démocrate vous fondez votre
vision sur la défense de la liberté
soient économiques sociales et
politiques en quoi cette liberté que
vous portez pour répondre aux
problématiques des zones rurales
est-ce que la disparition des services
publics dans certaines zones pourraient
être on va dire reste résolu grâce à
votre liberté
alors déjà je vais juste corriger
quelque chose c'est qu'effectivement
vous
nous demander de nous donc de nous de
parler de la ruralité est ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est qu'un député avant tout est
là pour être réélu pour voter des lois
ou pour en proposer
effectivement nous sommes élus de
territoire malgré tout donc ce
territoire en gros on y puise des
difficultés rencontrées pour les amener
donc à l'assemblée et pouvoir donc
instruit à proposer des lois qui peuvent
qui peuvent permettre de résoudre ces
problèmes pour la réalité par exemple on
peut imaginer qu'un député de paris aura
peut-être des moins bonnes du tout cas
on imagine les choses que je défends ne
sont pas forcément pour le terrifiant
j'y vois là mais déjà par rapport à tout
ce qui est dit je pense qu'il faut vivre
21e siècle à savoir qu' on est en train
d'envisager on l'entendait d'ailleurs
tout à l'heure peut-être des transports
supplémentaires d'écart supplémentaires
à côté de ça on défend le développement
durable donc qui dit car dit forcément
donc pollution donc c'est pas forcément
très cohérent peuvent être électrique
mais vu notre territoire c'est un petit
peu compliqué par rapport aux distances
ça c'est la première chose et puis il
faut pas oublier qu'on a quand même des
évolutions technologiques notamment je
pense aux google cars qui peuvent
permettre aujourd'hui d'éviter de
construire des infrastructures coûteuses
très coûteuse un gars et c'est alors que
demain chacun circulera avec une google
car qui emmènera une personne d'un
endroit à l'autre
c'est par c'est un exemple j'entendais
aussi tout à leur parler de fibre
optique alors qu'on va bientôt entendre
parler sur le territoire français de la
5g la saint-jean où on est on est en
retard vous vous dites il faut viser
plus haut on prend en france on a
toujours tendance
quand on a un problème le résoudre avec
les solutions que l'on a à notre portée
alors que guide il y à des solutions qui
arrive très très rapidement sur le
marché
je peux parler de la 5g qui vont pouvoir
résoudre toute une problématique
justement de
deux zones blanches dans certains
territoires encore faut-il construire
effectivement les antennes qui vont avec
et tout ça mais plutôt que de financer
des lignes de fibre optique
il faudrait peut-être mieux directement
passer à l'étape suivante à savoir
construire des antennes qui soit adaptée
pour la 5 g audrey queniez pour l'upm
vous proposés notamment par exemple pour
les services publics qui disparaît sur
certains territoires on le sait la
nationalisation totale ou partielle des
grandes entreprises c'est une priorité
ça si vous êtes élu député de porter ce
projet là nous vois je dirais que tout
d'abord on ne peut pas parler de
ruralité sans parler du désastre qui
touche aujourd'hui nos campagnes à
savoir le suicide de nos agriculteurs
il faut en compter en moyenne deux par
jour ce qui est absolument énorme et à
lui père nous voulons en priorité
protéger cette profession comment vous
faites cela alors par exemple par le
développement de ses magasins de ferme
pour réduire les circuits
d'approvisionnement et éventuellement
ouvrir le service civique à
l'agriculture pour ben justement retirer
ce poids de la solitude de nos
agriculteurs et pouvoir avoir un petit
peu de main d'oeuvre sur sur l'or sur
les exploitations
mais surtout pour éventuellement
réveiller des vocations chez nos jeunes
puisque aujourd'hui c'est plus du tout
une profession qui fait rêver puisque on
voit que malheureusement c'est un
désastre qui les touchent
nous voulons aussi milité pour le
plafonnement de la pac
sachez que l'union européenne l'a
proposé en 2013 et que ces sources est
sous pression de la fnsea que la france
l'a refusée alors que justement cette
place
ce plafonnement pourrait aider les tous
les agriculteurs bio les vingt-cinq
mille agriculteurs bio qui sont passés
donc trouver un qui sont faits cette
transition en 2015 et qui à ce jour
n'ont toujours pas touché les
subventions qu'ils devaient toucher
donc avant de d'édicter des nouvelles
lois déjà faisons appliquer celles qui
existent et qui aimait terme et on est
en place pour défendre entre autres nos
campagnes nous voulons bien évidemment
améliorer les transports de proximité et
là il s'agit pas de les développer mais
simplement de réhabiliter les lignes qui
existe aujourd'hui et qui ont été
complètement abandonnée donc c'est c'est
une chose qui est extrêmement importante
puisque aujourd'hui on propose aux
français d'aller de venir s'entasser
dans des cages à lapins
plutôt que va leur permettre d'aller
prendre un petit peu l'air dans les
campagnes bien évidemment aussi nous
militons pour l'aider à la fin des
déserts médicaux
justement en augmentant le numerus
clausus et une dernière chose une aux 36
1658 mère qui aujourd'hui sont
extrêmement importants pour nous et il
est hors de question que ces mères qui
sont aujourd'hui impacté par la loi
d'autres disparaissent on va avant de
passer à la deuxième thématique la
moralisation de la vie politique
on va regarder peut-être vos temps de
parole qui vont s'afficher dans quelques
secondes vous êtes plus ou moins à
égalité je crois savoir voilà voyez ça
se joue à quelques secondes avec
dominique chambon et laurent besson qui
ont quelques secondes de retard sur
audrey kuni je vous félicite tous les
trois ans pour que c'est du coup ajouter
une chose marketing alors allez-y si
vous voulez du coup à moins de temps
pour la viola parce que la question des
transports
elle est liée aussi à l'éloignement du
lieu de travail et il nous nous
proposons qu'il y ait des emplois de
créés dans les zones rurales des de
l'artisanat bien sûr l'agriculture qui
est déjà mais aussi des petites
entreprises bien intégré dans
l'environnement et des petits commerces
alors les petits commerces on voit par
exemple à son chant qui est pas loin de
chez moi un petit commerce
un jour c'est un magasin de vélos un
jour c'est une supérette les gens n'ont
pas tenu financièrement eh bien nous
proposons une aide publique pour que ces
commerces cela puisse vivre ils ont un
revenu minimum garanti est ce que vous
souhaitez éventuellement répondre on
poursuit l'émission on va peut-être la
poursuivre sur la moralisation de la vie
politique c'est l'actualité
la réforme a été présentée par françois
bayrou il ya quelques jours maintenant
elle prévoit notamment certaines
propositions importantes comme
l'interdiction pour les élus de cumuler
trois mandats successifs au niveau
national comme local sauf pour les
petites communes encore la suppression
de la réserve parlementaire qui fait
beaucoup parler question simple si vous
êtes élu à l'assemblée nationale
voterez-vous les différents projets de
loi qui sont proposés et pourquoi
laurent burson votre réponse à cette est
assez plutôt question
alors oui je la voterai j'ajouterai même
si elle ne va pas assez loin
puisque effectivement vous vous disiez
on parle qu'elle est que les élus locaux
seraient mis à l'écart de cette loi que
on parle de trois mandats et trois
mandats de député ça fait 15 ans pour
moi c'est beaucoup trop je pense que
demanda sont suffisants alors peut-être
pas pour tous parce qu'il y en a au bout
de 22 ans ils se rendent compte qu'il
faudrait peut-être faire des choses pour
la peau la ruralité mais mais toujours
est il que moi je considère que demande
assez suffisant partir du moment où
centre août je prends de ce terme là on
sent croûte au modèle public a droit à
deux mandats
oui tout à fait sur le même modèle la
partition sans croûte on le voit le vois
je le vois à maurepas où on avait il ya
trois ans quand on a repris la mairie on
avait une équipe précédente qui a fait
25 ans de mandat et la cdu local
on le voit il n'y a plus rien qui se
passe on est sur une routine journalière
est donc plus rien ne se passe et un
député pour moi c'est la même chose un
député au bout d'un an de un mandat deux
mandats il est pareil dans une routine
alors il nous parle ensuite de qu'il
connaît le territoire qu'il connaît les
gens qui râlent acquis qui sont sur ce
territoire
mais je le rappelle un député même s'il
connaît son territoire il est là pour
remonter les problématiques du
territoire et nous pas
faire du clientélisme notamment par
cette réserve alors parlementaire qui
aussi donc supprimés parce que oui
j'appelle ça vraiment du kiel du
clientélisme cette réserve parlementaire
audrey kuni pour le p r si vous êtes élu
vous aurez à vous prononcer dès cet été
sur deux projets de loi sur la réforme à
sion dire là sur ce projet de pour la
vie politique moralisation de la vie
politique
qu'est ce que vous ferez et pourquoi
justement je vais rejoindre et monsieur
bur sont sur ce point puisque pour moi
elle ne va pas du tout assez loin
puisque je vous disais en introduction
que j'ai fait partie de ces dégoûtés de
la politique pendant très longtemps et
bien que j'ai retrouvé en lui père de
l'éthique
sachez que mon casier judiciaire est
complètement vierge puisque c'est une
chose qu'on nous demande depuis dix ans
à lui ni à l'utm on le revendique on
veut à mettre 7 cette clause du casier
judiciaire vierge dans la loi de
moralisation chose que monsieur bayrou a
étrangement oublié dans son dans sa
proposition est donc nous nous
l'appliquons à nous mêmes sur ta toune
otunnu candidat à toutes les élections
européennes régionales
depuis dix ans nous voulons également
instauré un quorum de 60% pour voter
toute loi à l'assemblée puisque
aujourd'hui on voit que des lois sont
votées avec un ami n'a semblé
complètement vide et éventuellement
mettre des supprimer les intérêts les
indemnités en cas d'absentéisme trop
prononcé comme ces faits au sénat ou à
l'assemblée européenne
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas chez les
déchets les députés évidemment limitée à
deux mandats consécutifs ce qui serait
largement suffisant sauf dans les
petites communes de moins de 5000
habitants puisque c'est déjà compliqué
de trouver des candidats imposés le
référendum d'initiative populaire pour
redonner enfin leur voix aux français et
puis le vote blanc de plein exercice qui
est notre cheval de bataille depuis déjà
un bon moment à lui perd ce qui veut
dire que vous ne voterez pas la loi mais
vous en proposera peut-être une qui
irait plus loin c'est ça c'est pas une
première et un peu saoul et voilà c'est
ça voilà la compléter ce serait déjà
c'est une bonne c'est une bonne première
étape mais par contre effectivement
elles méritent d'être complétées très
largement dominique chambon la 10e une
remarque le l'assemblée nationale ce
n'est pas un peuple qui répond à
référendum par oui ou par non et on
mentionné l'idée des députés on est là
pour travailler en commissions groupes
et puis faire des contre-propositions
pour améliorer les lois on a un travail
de député à faire la question de vous
voterez vous vous voterez vous voterez
pas je peux pas répondre à cette
question on allait bien il ya des
avancées il a été dit je vais pas en
rajouter mais il ya des insuffisances
qui nous paraissent à nous
particulièrement importante
il faudra améliorer la protection de la
vie politique contre les conflits
d'intérêts et les pressions du monde de
l'argent et des milieux des affaires
parce que il ya quand même comment c'est
peut-être c'est peut-être une
coïncidence mais ça m'étonnerait que les
gens mouillé dans des affaires soient
des gens qui soient pas des employés des
ouvriers des gens du peuple ce sont des
gens qui font partie d'un monde quand
même de privilégier et qui défendent par
leurs lois
on y viendra tout à l'heure c'est
peut-être avec la carte blanche qui
défendent par leurs lois l'intérêt de
ceux de leur petit monde de privilégiés
voilà alors comment défendre des années
les conflits d'intérêts la pollution de
la vie politique d'oppression du monde
de l'argent bien si en votant des lois
qui permettent de de favoriser les
salariés ou des who détriment des
actionnaires par exemple alors on va
voir
réponse je voudrais juste rajouter
quelque chose parce qu'on en a parlé de
cette loi mais moi je pourrais parler
d'éthique parce que l'éthique ça se
légifère pas et même si effectivement le
gouvernement macron propose une loi sur
la moralisation aller public c'est tout
de même assez choquant de de demander
des choses mais à côté de ça de ne pas
être conformes aux choses demandées
quand on a un nez soi l'éthique parce
qu'il n'y a rien de prouvé légalement on
vient de référencer référence à
l'interféron tout à fait quand on n'a
notamment pas candidate locale qui se
défend d'être partie d'un parti pour
aller vers un autre parce que la sphère
fillon l'a dérangé je ne comprends pas
qu'elle ne fasse pas la même chose sur
la sphère ferrand bon ceci dit vu son
compte twitter ça voudrait dire qu'elle
viendrait au parti libéral alors vous
parlez droit voilà pourquoi bien sûr
mais c'est juste pour dire qu'il faut de
la cohérence en politique de l'éthique
mais aussi de la cohérence si on part
d'un parti pour une raison dans ce cas
là on en parle aussi pour la même raison
ailleurs je prends des buts et du chose
alors allez-y les leur magie moi ça me
file min 40 sur autre chose
nous voudrions créer un statut qui
démocratise la fonction d'élu qui permet
au salarié de s'investir dans dans des
fonctions représentatives tels que
député et qu'ils puissent ensuite
retrouvé leur place au travail
voilà ça permettra d'avoir une assemblée
nationale à l'image de la france et on
va regarder peut-être vos temps de
parole qui vont s'afficher à l'écran
avec désormais quelques écarts je crois
savoir on va voir ça s'afficher voilà
donc audrey queniez un peu de retard et
puylaurens bourses ont du coup vous avez
désormais un peu d'avancé on passe à la
carte blanche qui vous permet de mettre
le point que vous souhaitez en avant
avec uni pour le perron pour l'heure
inverse du début de l'émission
vous avez la parole en première bien moi
je voudrais mettre le point sur
l'économie puisque à lutter 1
nous sommes fermement opposés au traité
de libre échange comme le ceta ou le
taffetas sachez que vient d'être ratifié
un nouveau traité avec l'ukraine je vous
l'apprends peut-être et ses 173 euros de
mensuel de salaire c'est dire ce qui va
encore nous arriver dessus donc le péril
que met ses traités sur nous sur nos
lois environnementales et sociétales
puisque vienne a vécu aux également les
tribunaux arbitraux c'est ce qu'il faut
savoir
avec ses grosses entreprises privées qui
peuvent faire qui va peuvent prendre la
main sur les lois de nos gouvernements
nous voulons aussi refusé ces traités
puisque c'est une concurrence sauvage
sur nos tpe et nos pme que nous voulons
protéger à tout prix
en créant par exemple les fonds de
garantie par l'état
les crédits garantis par l'état pour
aider justement nos tpe
c'est une chose qui a été faite en 2008
pour sauver les banques pourquoi pas
protéger nos tpe par ce même biais nous
voulons également réduire les délais de
paiement puisque c'est une trés
aujourd'hui il était vieux voilà leur
trésorerie largement impacté par ces
délais de paiement à plus de 30 voire 45
jours et séparer les activités de dépôts
et de spéculation des banques pour
redynamiser l'économie réelle et surtout
éviter la crise tel qu'on l'a connu en
dominique chambon je rappelle avant de
vous donner la parole que vous êtes le
suppléant de la candidate communiste
corinne auribeau votre votre carte
blanche à vous vous avez un petit peu
moins de temps ça va être la casse du
code du travail et le nouveau code du
travail que nous on propose je vais être
très court sur sur les propositions
parce que je voudrais développer un peu
de financement
ce qu'on appelle quand tu as jusqu'à
maintenant donc en gros là les
ordonnances que
le président veut mettre en place c'est
pour que les salariés soient n'est plus
de protection vis-à-vis du patronat il
veut il veut que les gens puissent être
licencié sans raisons économiques que
les les accords se négocie dans
l'entreprise suffirait d'une pression un
chantage à l'emploi pour que les gens
acceptent n'importe quoi des baisses de
salaires c'est prévu des baisses de
salaires des augmentation du temps de
travail etc
nous on propose là al'inverse une loi de
déjà d'abroger la loi elle conneries ont
une loi emploi formation qui consiste à
donner aux gens la possibilité comme
sécurité sociale que l'on peut croiser
un commis cela a créé la possibilité aux
gens d'avoir un revenu garanti qu'il
travaille qu'il goûte il travaille pas
est-ce que j'ai le temps de parler du
financement alors vous aurez pas
beaucoup de monde en gros en choeur
déjà ces mesures là c'est un
investissement dans les trous demain qui
va rapporter
il ya 60 à 80 milliards de fraude
fiscale
il ya 56 milliards de dividendes et de
rachats d'actions version 2016
très bien merci pour j'ai conscience de
la difficulté évidemment de l'exercice
je vous invite une nouvelle fois
j'invite les téléspectateurs à aller
plus loin soit sur votre site internet
respectif ou en regardant vos tracts et
autres qu'ils recevront par courrier
laurent burson pour conclure sur cette
cette émission est sur cette carte
blanche pour le parti libéral démocrate
c'est de faire plus blanc je vous avais
beaucoup moins de temps que les oui bah
oui oui donc je vais essayer de faire
très court donc non ce que je voulais
dire c'était que au jour fin suite à
l'élection présidentielle l'ensemble de
l'échiquier électoral est complètement
rebattu les cartes sont rebattues et
nous allons assister dans le futur
effectivement à une modification de cet
échiquier et je représente
je suis tout comme je parlais des google
cars tout à l'heure je suis en avance
sur ce temps je représente la nouvelle
droite la droite qui qui ce qui n'est
qu'il n'est pas
donc cette cette droite arrogante qui
considère qu'on a là s'il compte qu'on
s'est tous et qu'on doit nous écouter
pour tous qui doit régler la façon dont
on vit même au sein de notre famille je
suis une droite qui justement permet
l'ouverture à toutes les familles et
donc je veux je sais amoureux c'est donc
je suis cette nouvelle droite
je suis en avance et donc je souhaite
que les électeurs effectivement me fasse
confiance des longs juin c'est la fin de
cette deuxième partie du débat pour la
10ème circonscription merci à vous trois
d'être venu en plateau dans quelques
instants les derniers candidats de la
10e circonscription des yvelines seront
avec nous avant cela les précisions sur
les enjeux du territoire avec ce
reportage de nicolas d'andré un
territoire entre ruralité et zones
urbaines la 10e circonscription recouvre
le sud-est du département des yvelines
de ville de près de vingt mille
habitants en rambouillet et maurepas et
plusieurs communes rurales entouré de
village comme montfort l'amaury ou saint
père nous en yvelines
au coeur des enjeux sur ce territoire
l'agriculture avec plus de 50 % de
surfaces agricoles cultivées les
attentes sont importantes sur ce secteur
dominé par l'activité céréalières et
maraîchères
autre thématique dominante la ruralité
lors du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle dans cette
circonscription
emmanuel macron est arrivé en tête avec
27 89% des voix talonnée par françois
fillon
avec 27% des suffrages arrive ensuite
jean luc mélenchon et marine le pen à 15
% et 14 % député sortant jean-frédéric
poisson se présente sous les couleurs du
parti chrétien-démocrate investi par les
républicains il veut accéder à une
troisième législature avec la volonté de
poursuivre son travail dans le domaine
de la lutte contre le terrorisme
face à lui la candidate de la république
en marche aurore bergé conseillère
communautaire à saint quentin en
yvelines
ex-membre du parti les républicains elle
a rallié emmanuel macron pendant la
campagne présidentielle
elle s'engage notamment sur les
thématiques de l'égalité homme-femme du
progressisme et de l'union européenne
en embuscade face à ce duel annoncé
benjamin nicoletta sous la bannière de
la france insoumise il doit faire face à
la division
de la gauche le maire socialiste de
saint-arnoult jean claude husson corinne
auribeau pour le pcf ou encore l'élu
rambolitains l'écologiste david jutier
autres divisions du côté front national
françois le hôte devra faire face à
philippe chevrier président du parti du
front libérés ils soutiennent tous les
deux une position souverainiste et
protectionniste dans le domaine
économique et sociétal au total les
électeurs auront le choix parmi cette
liste de quatorze candidats sur une
circonscription ancrée à droite depuis
excepté en 2010 lors d'une élection
législative partielle qui avait vu la
victoire de l'écologiste anny poursinoff
face à jean frédéric poisson
plus de 88 mille électeurs sont appelés
aux urnes ce dimanche 11 juin alors ccc
le sait le direct nous sommes
actuellement avec deux candidates en
plateau on à monsieur fonsala ce qui va
chercher
l'organe la dernière candidate et vous
allez vous installer en direct en
plateau mais je fonce à l'as voilà pour
vous installer ici nous sommes avec vous
pour la dernière partie où il fit
chaussée pradère partie de ce débat du
coup avec marielle saunier candidat
d'extrême gauche investi par lutte
ouvrière marie thérèse mon manteau ni et
excusez-moi candidate divers gauche
investi par le parti nouvelle donne
l'organe va probablement nous rejoindre
candidat écologiste investi par le parti
anti persiste citoyens pour la
transparence et l'éthique et enfin
frédéric fonsala ce candidat
divers-droite investi par 577 les
indépendants bonsoir à sous les 3 je
vous rappelle que votons paroles sont
scrupuleusement chronométrés par les
membres de la rédaction ce qui ne vous
empêche pas bien sûr de débattre entre
vous et de répondre à vos opposants
politiques de ce soit vous connaissez
évidemment la première question pourquoi
les électeurs doivent t'ils ou faire
confiance dimanche l'organe installez
vous je vous ai présenté
on commence avec vous marier le saunier
pour lutte ouvrière pourquoi doivent-ils
vous faire confiance dimanche les
électeurs
alors si je me présente pour lutte
ouvrière en fait on est dans la
continuité de
a campagne électorale
nathalie arthaud pour les
présidentielles et donc on est là pour
présenter des candidats dans toutes les
circonscriptions en métropole mais aussi
en guadeloupe en martinique sur l'île de
la réunion en partie pour présenter un
programme pour défendre le camp des
travailleurs
donc c'est ce qui nous semble le plus
important et le plus de gens aujourd'hui
avec une série de mesures qui sont tout
simplement font partie d'un programme de
lutte
1 d'abord l'interdiction des
licenciements avec répartition du
travail entre tous sans perte de salaire
aucun salaire aucune pension aucun
revenu en fait aucune allocation en
dessous de 1800 euros par mois c'est le
minimum pour vivre à peu près dignement
dans cette société en france en tout cas
aujourd'hui
et puis le contrôle des comptes parce
que sinon comment appliquer tout ça il
faudra contre qu'on contrôle vraiment
les comptes
marie thérèse manteau ni pour nouvelle
donne pourquoi les électeurs doivent
t'ils vous faire confiance
alors nouvelle donne je voudrais vous
représentez nouvelle donne qui est
repartie relativement récent qui a été
lancée en novembre 2013 par l'économiste
pierre larrouturou nouvelle donne c'est
la traduction de new deal a inspiré du
courant de
du parti politique créé par oswald en
1930 au moment dans la période de grande
dépression et
et donc nouvelle donne s'inspire de 2 du
plan des plans des idées de roosevelt
parce qu'on considère que actuellement
un peu partout en france mais un peu
partout dans le monde
on revit une période difficile de
dépression dans tous les sens du terme
sur différentes thématiques
voilà donc depuis sa création nouvelle
donne se positionne clairement sur des
questions sociales environnementales
économiques et pour le renouvellement
des pratiques démocratiques
j'ai voilà j'exerce à l'éducation
nationale je suis membre et soutien de
différentes associations des ong qui
aspirent à plus de justice sociale
notamment dans les domaines de la santé
de l'éducation de l'économie et qui
lutte pour le bien commun l'intérêt
général merci l'organe pour le pacte
expliquez-nous pourquoi les électeurs
doivent t'ils voté pour vous je rappelle
et le pacte qui veut dire le parti anti
p67 citoyens pour la transparence et
l'éthique voilà pourquoi les électeurs
doivent voter pour vous ou alors moi je
suis une candidate qui est donc
citoyenne donc avec de fortes valeurs
républicaines je suis inscrit dans un
mouvement en fait de petits partis qui
tend vers une représentativité réelle
c'est à dire que nous on veut sortir de
la logique majorité-opposition je vois
république en marche qui investit tout
plein de candidats en disant bon bah
c'est pour la majorité présidentielle
pour moi ça autant je comprends qu'on
puisse vouloir avoir des députés qui
vont un petit peu dans notre sens pour
pouvoir appliquer sa politique autant
avoir un candidat qui arrive en plateau
et qui dit moi mon programme c'est de
voter sans sourciller
tout ce que proposera le
le gouvernement je trouve ça en tant que
citoyenne très problématique
moi je suis voire effrayant pour moi
c'est c'est constitutif d'une atteinte à
la séparation des pouvoirs
ni plus ni moins et je trouve ça grave
en démocratie alors on y habituer c'est
la logique habituelle mais moi ça me
convient pas et je sais que bon
traditionnellement on dit il faut donc
une majorité une position et à quand
l'opposition donc au niveau des
législatives quand tigana une
cohabitation etc
je pense vraiment qu'on peut dépasser ça
je vois pas pourquoi le pouvoir seraient
bloqués quand on a des députés qui tout
simplement fou leur travail vote donc en
fonction de ce qu'on nous présente moi
je voterais pour des deux mains
certaines propositions dodge décombres
attrait avec force
est ce qu'on représente on va papa parti
on représente des citoyens et donc voilà
je m'inscris dans ce mouvement là
frédéric foncel à terminer ce premier
tour de table pour 577 les indépendants
pour les électeurs doivent t'ils vous
faire confiance
eh bien je suis père de famille j'habite
à rambouillet depuis 91 j'ai travaillé
dans un des grands sites industriels de
rambouillet qui était philips qui est
devenu continental il ya un an j'étais
arrivé devant ce que j'appelle le
désarroi du bulletin de vote
je me rendais bien compte que la vie
politique ne produisait plus de
solutions et j'ai rencontré jean
christophe fromantin qui était
entrepreneur qui est devenu député
député maire de neuilly et lutter député
maire de neuilly et qui lui a constaté
par son expérience réelle à l'assemblée
que le système est bloqué et pour lui le
système est bloqué pour deux raisons la
professionnalisation de la politique
d'une part et d'autre part le
quinquennat qui fait qu'on pense que
l'élection d'un seul homme va résoudre
tous les problèmes pour résoudre ça il a
proposé de créer ce mouvement 577 les
indépendants qui est basé sur deux
principes faire monter des gens de la
vie civile des gens qui ont une
expérience concrète il ya un commissaire
de police il ya des gens non dans
l'entreprise des gens dans l'éducation
et la deuxième chose c'est qu'on porte
ensemble une loi de programme qui est un
mécanisme qu'on réfléchit depuis 18 mois
avec six volets et qui a pour vocation
d'attaquer tout ce qui n'a pas été
résolu depuis 25 ans pour faire court
depuis 25 ans on a passé deux mesures
dans tous les domaines et quand on
regarde le fonctionnement de
france il est totalement combrée par cet
amas de mesure qui coûte très cher mais
qui rendent surtout le système inopérant
et c'est pour ça que je me présente
aujourd'hui
merci à tous les quatre on passe à la
première thématique de ce débat là même
que les précédents la ruralité la 10e
circonscription des yvelines est
logiquement la plus rurale du
département vous le savez marie thérèse
manteau ni votre priorité à vous si vous
êtes élu député le 18 juin qu'elle quel
projet vous pourrez par exemple porter
vous souhaitez porter pour la ruralité
et du coup pour les électeurs de la 10e
circonscription des yvelines pour
nouvelle donne la question de la
ruralité elle et elle est transversale
ainsi on se base sur le dernier
recensement ce quand on parle de
ruralité ça concerne 35 % de la
population sur 90% du territoire et 60 %
quand on est sur un secteur
semi rural c'est dire que la question de
la ruralité les centrales clefs de
lecture des changements qui affectent
l'ensemble de notre société
parler de la ruralité
ça ne se limite pas à la question de
l'agriculture c'est tout ce qu'ils
touchent différents domaines et
notamment aussi le tissu la
diversification économique donc et les
problèmes rencontrés par les maires
ruraux sont finalement les mêmes que
rencontrent les maires des petites
communes notamment avec la mise en place
de la loi notre donc nous au niveau de
nouvelles donnes s'agissant de cette loi
notre on a été bons on a rencontré des
maires ruraux qui nous ont dit mais
cette loi nous on peut pas elle est
difficilement applicable parce que tu
référence voilà tout à fait ans qui vise
effectivement cette on va dire cette
nouvelle structure
2 comment dire on va dire ce encore une
structure supplémentaire qui vient
compliquer les choses qui a créé de
nombreux bouleversements dans la vie
politique des changements humains qui
n'ont pas été accompagnés et par moments
et bien oui
les élus locaux ne s'y retrouve plus et
souhaite que l'on puisse concrètement
trouver des solutions parce que certains
points de cette loi ne sont pas
applicables
il demande à ce qu'un groupe de travail
soit mis en place au niveau
parlementaire et nous les soutiens nous
les soutenons dans cette démarche pour
pouvoir discuter avec des élus et et
voir comment on peut faire évoluer les
choses parce que là ça ne va pas du tout
frédéric fonds salaces votre mouvement
propose la création de grands pôles
territoriaux
qu'en est il du coup de la ruralité et
vous qui venez maire de rambouillet
alors effectivement dans notre loi de
programme dont j'ai parlé il ya six
piliers mais le pilier numéro un c'est
la restructuration du territoire parce
que nous sommes arrivés à une complexité
de fonctionnement tels que nous nous ne
sommes plus opérationnel
notre proposition c'est de restructurer
la france en huit régions qu'ils soient
des pôles économiques centre et en
particulier autour des ports et entre
ces huit régions fort ça ira encore plus
loin que les régions actuelles alors ça
va beaucoup plus loin parce que ça n'est
pas un découpage administratif
quand on prend toutes les cartes de
france des différentes grandes
entreprises de la géographie on tombe
sur huit régions logique
architecturé autour de nantes bordeaux
marseille lyon strasbourg lille paris
ouvert sur la mer par le havre et
clermont ferrand se saurait les pôles
économiques avec un diamètre d'une heure
et demie entre ces huit régions et les
30000 commune nous créerions 450
territoire qui aurait à peu près le
périmètre des communautés de communes
actuelles la conséquence de tout ça
c'est une économie de fonctionnement de
50 milliards d'euros
cinquante mille veut réinvestir pour la
ruralité bien sûr il faudrait inverser
mais je veux le comparer à l'impôt total
qu'on prélève sur les sociétés qui est
de 57
aujourd'hui on engloutit dans la
complexité administrative l'intégralité
de l'impôt qu'on prélève sur les
sociétés ces 450 territoire aurait des
présidentes territoire bien
mais les députés seraient sur le même
territoire et la représentation de
l'état sur le même territoire
et là on aurait une structure
opérationnelle qui permettrait de
traiter le territoire en fonction de ses
spécificités parce que vous parler de
ruralité
moi j'ai piloté un projet de
développement sur rambouillet avec la
communauté en fait c'est un territoire
urbain
on est quand même à 30 minutes de
montparnasse on n'est pas la creuse et
tout ça c'est des spécificités que seul
le local peut traiter
il faut lui donner les moyens de le
faire marielle saunier pour lutte
ouvrière vous qui venez par exemple du
domaine hospitalier est ce que c'est par
exemple vous souhaitez agir sur les
déserts médicaux vous peut-être une
autre priorité pour vous sur les
infirmières dans un grand hôpital
parisien
donc on sait bien que les grosses
structures sont nécessaires 1 ces voix
là parce que en fait ça permet de faire
la recherche ça permet
de faire de former un bon ça c'est
essentiel
mais en fait ce dont les gens ont besoin
c'est d'avoir un accès aux soins partout
alors à chaque fois j'entendais en fait
d'aider 071 y en a de toutes sortes nous
en
en invente à chaque élection ce qu'on
constate c'est que les mesures des uns
et des autres contribuent et on continue
dans ce sens là aujourd'hui à fermer
voilà des hôpitaux entier et des
cliniques
maintenant il ya assez de personnes
assez de médecins par exemple pour des
hôpitaux partout il y en a pas assez
mais si vous parlez de la formation des
médecins il ya quand même le problème du
numerus clausus qui en fait limite
1 le nombre de médecins formés chaque
année et du coup les hôpitaux
fonctionnent avec des médecins étrangers
qui sont payés du son au salaire d'une
infirmière mais qui font beaucoup plus
d'heures que les 35 heures théoriques
on va dire mais en fait la ruralité
c'est aussi le problème du désengagement
de l'état qui laisse le soin à chacun de
se débrouiller avec ce qu'il a ou plutôt
ce qu'il a pas et on en vient toujours
un gros problème de ce fonctionnement de
cette société qui en fait l'état lui ne
fait des économies et les économies les
faits sur le dos des gens voilà sur le
dos de la population et se désengage de
tout ce qui est utile à la population un
ça va pour les hôpitaux mais ça va pour
tout le reste pour les écoles je pense
que dans fin voilà on sait que dans dans
les petits villages c'est toujours très
compliqué
ne serait-ce que d'emmener les enfants à
l'école l'organe vous avez vous une
approche plutôt écologistes vous
défendez aussi la cause animale
quelles sont par exemple quelle est
votre priorité à vous si vous êtes élu
un député de la 10e circonscription pour
la pour la ruralité pour la réalité bon
comme tout le monde tombe bien sûr on a
un aspect écologique donc se serait
développée tout ce qui est enfin
accompagner une transition verte mais
pas que mes donc ce serait
l'agroforesterie des choses comme ça
essayez de à d'aider les agriculteurs à
faire cette transition a également
baissé
du coup les taux de nitrates dans les
eaux qui sont assez élevés sur la
circonscription par l'endroit mais
également en soucie également donc de la
population locale à savoir quand on est
re ruraux il est important de pouvoir
bien être bien vivre et bien vieillir
dans son cadre de vie sans qu'ils soient
détruits sans qu'ils soient aménagés par
des décisions venues d'en haut
d'ailleurs et c'est très important pour
nous en fait de rester dans une écoute
de la population et de pas imposé par
exemple des antennes relais tout les
simples lettres pour la 4g sous
couverture de enfin pont parlant de
fracture numérique alors que par
ailleurs on a de bonnes démarches qui
est deux à financer la fibre donc le
fctt à je te dire de la fif directement
à l'abonné on a des aides pour le
satellite pas je veux dire l'accès à
internet pour nouer est primordial
également parce que ça permet à des
ruraux donc deux à pouvoir développer
des entreprises sur place du télétravail
est ce qu on époux l'écologie mais je
suis également pour une sorte
d'écosystème au niveau de la ruralité
donc bien sûr non pas ça il n'y a pas
besoin de détailler vous retrouverez sur
notre programme toutes les mesures en
fonction pour le bio etc
mais c'est également un écosystème de la
vie qu'on puissent simplement vivre
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec ce que
disait madame sur l'accès aux soins
voilà au niveau de la perrine et ces
parias il ya beaucoup de choses à faire
on va voir on va voir vos temps de
parole s'afficher à l'écran d'ici
quelques secondes lors que vous êtes
tous à peu près au même temps de parole
ça va s'afficher voilà un petit peu
d'avancé pour l'organe envoyer ses très
proches
marie thérèse mme anthony également je
sais pas
on va passer voilà la deuxième
thématique la moralisation de la vie
politique c'est dans l'actualité
si vous êtes élu député vous aurez à
vous prononcer dès cet été sur deux
projets de loi alors ma question est
simple est-ce que vous voterez pour et
pourquoi on va commencer avec vous ma
maman tony est ce que vous voterez pour
et pourquoi alors cette loi constitue ce
projet de loi constituent des avancées
malheureusement bon jeu
j'avoue que je me perds un petit peu
parce qu'en première lecture de points
qui nous semblent essentielles à
nouvelle donne deux points
la première lecture à l'assemblée
nationale au 1er février
deux points essentiels ont été adoptés
et la semaine dernière ont été retirés
de la loi donc nous on continuera à
militer pour ça notamment l'interdiction
pour tous les détenteurs d'un casier
judiciaire niveau b de se présenter à
une élection alors pourquoi ça avait été
adoptée au 1er février 2016 2017 et
pourquoi ça a été retirée la semaine
dernière ça pose question
deuxièmement laisser la prévention de la
corruption aussi qui était qui était qui
avait été adopté dans un premier temps
et prévention de la corruption dans les
collectivités territoriales et
l'encadrement strict du lobbying avec
notamment la publication par les
parlementaires de leur rendez vous avec
des représentants de d'intérêt
donc nous continuerons à nous battre
dans
pour que ces avancées soient enfin que
ces points soit remis au niveau de la
loi
sachant qu'il y a aussi encore des
choses à améliorer notamment la
suppression de tout lien payer rares
chic entre le procureur et les
magistrats du parquet et le ministre la
justice est enfin là un thème qui nous
tient très à coeur et et qui nous pose
problème parce que celui là on a on a du
mal à le faire supprimer c'est le verrou
de bercy qui donne à l'exécutif le
monopole des poursuites en matière de
fraude fiscale
alors uniquement au ministère du budget
et sans qu'on puisse vraiment les
magistrats puissent agir en toute
transparence et enquêter librement vous
fait passer les cinq minutes à l'instant
on va enchaîner avec n'y a pas eu
d'appel il ya pas de panique fennecs eux
font ça lasse qu'est ce que est ce que
vous voterez vous 7,7 fois et pourquoi
on voit pas bien pourquoi on voterait
pas une loi qui prône la morale
maintenant
ça renvoie un des piliers de notre loi
de programme qui s'appelle la
gouvernance et les institutions et nous
nous nous sommes pour la montée des
députés et des acteurs politiques depuis
la vie civile parce que celles qui les
nourrit c'est quand on était d'en être
quand on est allé dans une entreprise
dans un hôpital dans une école qu'on
sait vraiment ce qui s'y passe par
exemple l'application concrète à
d'autres mouvements c'est qu'on a dû
trouver chacun sans soutien à nos
circonscriptions
oui et donc ça ça me paraît être un
moyen efficace pour vérifier que les
gens ont l'adhésion et la confiance
il ya toutes les années des enquêtes du
cevipof qui paraît en janvier quitte qui
pose la question de la confiance des
français en politique
et quand on demande aux français pensez
vous que le président de la république
va résoudre les problèmes
la réponse est à 80% non quand vous
descendez dans la hiérarchie vous
arrivez en proximité
le taux de confiance monte à 60 70 %
donc notre mouvement 577 part du bas
pour cette raison là donc ça va bien au
delà de la morale évidemment la morale
il faut qu'elle y soit mais d'ailleurs
ci aurait pas eu la terre fillon est-ce
que ça serait la première mesure
comprendrait je sais pas trop en tout
cas ce qui est important c'est la
politique comme un service est pas la
politique comme métier
marielle saunier on sait ce que vous
pouvez potentiellement pas annoncé de la
politique d' emmanuel macron notamment
économique est ce que cette loi là vous
lave auto riez vous savez moi je suis
communiste un mail lutte ouvrière nom de
semoule de voilà nous sommes communiste
alors je vais vous dire enfin on
s'étonne même pas enfin je ne sais pas
ça fonctionne comme ça ça te dirait ça
fonctionne comme ça le système
capitaliste fonctionne comme ça il ya
des accointances évidente entre les
hommes politiques qui gouvernent et donc
on s'en mêler et les grandes entreprises
et les patrons le les gouvernements ils
sont au service de ces gens là quand
même des gros actionnaires des grands
banquiers
des grandes familles du cac 40 alors de
quoi on parle là c'est absolument
ridicule
écoutez franchement vous savez quoi moi
en fait moi il ya un truc il ya une
référence dans l'histoire un tous les
travailleurs pour toute la population
c'est la commune de paris parce que
pendant la commune du par uys et en 1871
ils ont décrété ils ont appliqué une
mesure très simple c'est les élus sont
révocables à tout moment et ils sont
payés au salaire moyen d'un travailleur
alors vous savez ce sera une question
habilité politique voilà c'est toujours
la question quand même pas vous faudra
que je sais bien mais c'est toujours ce
qu'on nous renvoie
mais vous savez je crois que les gens
sont plus responsables qu'on ne croit 1
et puis quand quand les gens quand la
population quand les travailleurs
décident quelque chose et désigne
quelqu'un pour être leur porte parole
parce que c'est ça normalement
ce qui devrait être en place et bien
cette personne applique ce qu'on m'a
demandé de faire pourquoi elle ferait
autrement la vôtre alors ça c'est pas
comme ça que ça marche
c'est ça le problème c'est que oui mais
c'est pas comme ça que ça marche
en fait alors là on est élu on élit des
députés mais enfin depuis quand les
députés font exactement les embolies
font exactement ce qu'on leur a demandé
ce pourquoi ils ont été élus les
promesses qu'ils ont faites d'accord
donc surtout fallait j'ai terminé là
dessus c'est que voilà il faut être
révocable à tout moment je suis pour la
démocratie directe
l'organe est ce que vous vous voteriez
c'est ce projet c'est le parti donc des
sites citoyens pour la transparence et
l'éthique donc bien entendu une nouvelle
loi sur la moralisation public
ça nous parle pour autant pas comme tous
les candidats sur les candidats en lice
sur le plateau bah oui j'aurais aimé que
ça aille plus loin après je suis
réaliste c'est déjà un premier pas est
un premier pas dans le bon sens ça
répond à l'attenté des citoyens donc oui
je la voterai après nous ce qu'on
aimerait et moi ce que ce que ce que
j'aimerais c'est voir en france un petit
peu ce qu'on a pu voir dans des
reportages sur ce qui se passe par
exemple en finlande où on souhaite on
voit des ministres qui qui vivent tous
normalement qui vont à leur cantine qui
marchent dans la rue qui sont des
citoyens normaux au service d'autres
citoyens
c'est très important et nous sommes par
ailleurs pour une baisse drastique des
indemnités de tous nos représentants et
donc également des gens du gouvernement
et je pense que ce serait une très bonne
chose
on dit toujours que si on avait un
salaire trop basse par exemple on les
mettait tous au smic
peut-être y aurait plus de corruption
parce que c'est trop éloignés des
salaires du privé par rapport à leur
qualification de ça je suis pas du tout
convaincu pour ça parce que tout
simplement ça n'empêche pas la
corruption quand ils ont de gros
salaires
et puis je trouve que ça les mettrait
vraiment dans l'esprit et pour les gens
de vraiment l'idée que quand on a ce
mandat qui n'est pas une carrière
politique
on représente le pape on est au service
des gens c'est ce vraiment pour moi ça
passerait par une réduction des salaires
et donc voilà safran sera important et
après si on se dit que bah je sais pas à
tant de temps d'euros ou 1 smic
ce serait trop difficile pour vivre
c'est souvent ce qu'on me dit quand je
dis ça aussi mais dans ce cas c'est
difficile pour vivre pour vous et les
autres
voilà une ce cas là il faut travailler
là dessus monsieur fonsala vous avez un
peu de retard sur le temps de parole ce
que vous acquiescez ce qui ce qui venait
d'être dit tout ce que vous souhaitez
réagir ou peut-être gardé pour la carte
blanche voir le mode servi seul mot clé
services et pas métier service n'est pas
se servir
voilà on va voir vos temps de paroles
qui s'affichent avant de passer à la
carte blanche et qui vous permettra de
mettre en avant le point que vous
souhaitez ça va s'afficher à l'écran
tout de suite vous allez voir voilà on
est presque à égalité me suis fonsala ce
vous avez quand même une minute de
retard ça vous laissera plus de temps
pour pour la carte blanche
et puis on part dans le sens inverse du
début de ce débat donc vous avez
d'ailleurs la parole pour 577 les
indépendants votre carte blanche bien
comme je vous ai dit que notre lot
programme des six volets j'en ai
expliqué deux jeux en un clic à trois
autres
alors est-ce parce que quand on regarde
les paramètres de la france au moment où
on arrive on a quand même 10% de chômage
on a 25 % de chômage chez les 18 25 ans
on a perdu 7 5% de part de marché en
europe depuis dix ans on a une dette qui
est à 100 % du chiffre 2 du pib alors
qu'elle était à 20% dans les années 80
tout ça c'est le résultat d'une inaction
donc pour agir contre ça on a trois
volets essentiels le premier c'est de
remettre nos entreprises au niveau de
compétitivité des grands voisins en
baissant essentiellement les charges sur
capital et travail et les remontant sur
les produits finis le deuxième qui va en
pendante ça parce qu'on rentre dans un
nombre d'entrepreneurs
c'est un volet social qui prend 47
dispositif non contributifs qui vont des
allocations familiales ou rs en passant
par les apl qui est un maquis
inextricable savez vous qui a la moitié
des gens qui ont droit au rsa qui ne le
demande pas ça fait 80 milliards on
remplace tout ça par une allocation 250
euros par enfant quel que soit le nombre
d'enfants
la famille 700 euros par adulte qui n'a
rien évidemment c'est plus cumulable n'y
a plus rien d'autre et ce 700 euros
encourage au retour rapide à l'emploi
parce que pour gagner 100 200 300 euros
qui sépare du seuil de pauvreté c'est
pas très difficile et on baisse à ce
moment-là lentement le 700 qui disparaît
totalement quand le salaire arrive dans
la zone de 1600 et troisième volets
l'éducation et la formation puisqu'on
est aujourd'hui un des uns des pays qui
paye le plus cher par enfant et qui a
les résultats quasiment les plus mauvais
et la première mesure c'est remonter le
salaire d'embauché des professeurs de
1400 à 2000
parce que la qualité des professeurs est
le premier paramètre de succès du
système
on poursuit avec l'organe vous avez je
le sais c'est difficile comme il insiste
un peu moins de temps pour le pacte
votre carte blanche j'aimerais beaucoup
de cartes blanches donc du coup j'ai en
profiter pour faire passer un message
pour des personnes qui sont pas
électoralement rentable mais qui me
tient à coeur donc bien sûr les animaux
compte aussi pour moi et plein d'autres
sujets mais vous pouvez le retrouver sur
le programme du pacte mais je voudrais à
un petit mot sur la périnatalité et
notamment pour les sages-femmes
ad c'est à dire les sages femmes qui
font des accouchements à domicile elles
doivent avoir accès à une assurance
professionnelle abordable parce qu'elles
doivent pouvoir rester jaguar doivent
pouvoir exercer leur métier dans de
bonnes conditions est resté accessible à
toutes les femmes
ça n'a pas être un âne et un privilège
je suis également pour les maisons
distance et pour le respect donc de
toutes les femmes
voilà et également pour un meilleur
accueil et de meilleurs moyens dans les
maternités pour tous les soignants comme
pour les patients merci maritaise
manteau ni pour une nouvelle donne votre
carte blanche
plusieurs choses à lire vos limites
bildt oui je voulais revenir sur
l'esprit de corruption notamment avec
ce deuxième point sur la prévention de
la corruption dans les collectivités
territoriales il nous tient
particulièrement à coeur parce qu'on
sait qu'avec les lois de
décentralisation la corruption 6 et
décentralisé donc c'est il ya quand même
un vaste chantier
enfin on parle beaucoup de la
moralisation ce qu'on entend
actuellement par la moralisation de la
vie publique
c'est la vie politique mais à côté des
politiques il y a aussi des hauts
fonctionnaires et si on ne se penche pas
sur les nominations des hauts
fonctionnaires
à un moment donné la corruption on va le
retrouver à ce niveau là parce que la
frontière n'est pas très très étanche
entre les deux et que il y a à certains
moments notamment dans un recrutement
accordéon en cas en cas de crise ce qui
est dans la fonction publique dé
promotion qui sont faibles des gens qui
font carrière qui vise leur intérêt
personnel contre le col est l'intérêt
général
voilà enfin marielle saulnier pour lutte
ouvrière vous avez précisément 40 45
secondes pour votre carte blanche c'est
précis pas compte de ce que ça fait en
fait mon couperet on va voilà enfin ça
en fait le plus gros problème c'est
quand même le chômage le chômage et les
salaires parce que là on va revenir sur
les axes de campagne
moi je vais désolé mais c'est essentiel
d'interdire les licenciements et les
suppressions de postes parce que l'état
il fait la même chose que les grandes
entreprises qui font des profits ou pas
d'ailleurs
enfin on ouvrirait les comptes on ne
saurait mais en tout cas l'état quand il
supprime des postes
c'est du chômage au bout c'est des
emplois que les gens ne trouvent pas
donc ça c'est essentiel d'interdire les
licenciements de contrôler les comptes
des entreprises
et puis on revient sur les 1800 euros
c'est serré c'est essentiel c'est le
minimum pour vivre c'est pas à faye a
quand même 76 milliards de profits pour
les entreprises du cac40 l'année
dernière donc cet argent il doit revenir
à tout le monde aux salariés aux
chômeurs ont réparti le travail ans
entre tout le monde n'y a pas de raison
de faire le boulot qu'avant on faisait à
4 maintenant faut
il faut le faire à trois voire à 2 donc
non ont réparti le travail entre tous
merci à tous les quatre d'être venu en
plateau on va dernière fois au revoir
peut-être la liste de l'ensemble des
candidats sur cette 10e circonscription
des yvelines à l'écran en tout cas je
vous remercie à tous d'être venus
vous serez 15 candidats présents pour le
premier tour dimanche 11 juin merci
aussi à vous de nous avoir suivis et
débat se poursuivre cette semaine sur
tes fils avec celui de la 11e
circonscription ce mercredi est la
douzième jeudi les replays eux sont
disponibles sur internet où notre
application tv fil 78 excellente soirée
à tous
[Musique]